a public bill Committee in December last
year we are therefore debating today
only the new Clauses and amendments
listed on the selection paper issued
today
these are either new Clauses relating to
the recommitted Clauses and schedules
amendments to those Clauses and
schedules or amendments to other parts
of the bill consequential on changes
made to the bill on re-committal in the
public bill committee
on December the 5th the house finished
its consideration on report of other
parts of the bill the scope of today's
report stage generally does not include
those parts of the bill that were not
recommitted the exception is where
amendments on the selection are
consequential to the changes made to
recommitted Clauses and relate to
Clauses that were not recommitted
should there be time for debate on third
reading it is of course permissible to
speak then to any of the content of the
bill
I should also remind the house that
because of the time taken for the
Emergency debate
proceedings on consideration
are now scheduled to finish at eight
fifth to 8 13 p.m and proceedings on
third reading at 9 13 P.M
we start with new Clause one with which
it will be convenient to consider the
other new Clauses and amendments as on
this selection paper I call Shadow
Minister Alex Davis Jones whose new
Clause one and Deputy speaker once again
it is a privilege to be back in the
chamber opening at this debate to the
third report stage debate in recent
months of this incredibly important and
urgently needed piece of legislation I
speak on behalf of colleagues across the
house when I say that the bill is in a
much worse position than when it was
first introduced it is therefore vital
that is now able to progress to the
other place although we are all pleased
to see the bill returned today the
government's delays have been incredibly
costly and we still have a long way to
go until we see meaningful change for
the better Madame represent speaker in
December during the last report stage
debate we had the immense privilege to
be joined by a number of the families
who have all lost children in connection
with online Harms in the public Gallery
it is these family who we must keep in
our mind when we seek to get this bill
over the line once and for all and as
ever I pay tribute to their incredible
efforts in the most difficult of all
circumstances
today's debate is also very timely in
that earlier today the end violence
against women and girls Coalition and
glitch a charity committed to ending
online abuse handed in their petition
which calls on the prime minister to
protect women and girls online the
petition has so far amassed more than 90
000 signatures and it is rising so we
know that there is a strong support for
improving Internet safety across the
board and I commend all of those
involved for their fantastic efforts in
raising this important issue
but Madam Deputy speaker it would be
remiss of me not to make a brief comment
on the government's last minute u-turns
around this stance on criminal sanctions
the fact that we are seeing amendments
withdrawn at the last minute goes to
show that this government have
absolutely no idea where they truly
stand on these issues the fact that they
are ultimately too weak stand up against
vested interest whereas labor are on the
side of the public and have consistently
put safety at the Forefront throughout
the Bill's passage Madame Deputy speaker
more broadly I made Labor's feelings
about the government's highly unusual
decision to send parts of this bill back
to committee for a second time very
clear during the debate so I will spare
colleagues by not repeating those
frustrations here today
but let me be clear it is absolutely
wrong that the government chose to
remove safety Provisions relating to the
so-called legal but harmful content as
they did so in committee it is a major
weakening not strengthening of the bill
and all of us online including users and
consumers will be worse off without
these provisions
the government's alternative proposal to
introduce a toggle to filter out harmful
content is completely unworkable
replacing the sections of this bill that
could have gone some way to preventing
harm with an emphasis of freeze on the
Free Speech undermines the very purpose
of this bill and will embolden abusers
covert deniers hoaxes and others who
will feel encouraged to thrive online in
committee the government also chose to
remove important Clauses from the bill
that were in place to keep adults safe
online
without the all-important risk
assessments for adults I must press the
minister on an important point exactly
how will this bill do anything to keep
adults safe online
the government knows this and have still
pursued a course of action which will
put see the bill watered down entirely
good boy um I think we're friends
forgiving way does my older friendly
there is clear evidence that legal but
harmful content is often the gateway to
far more dangerous radicalization and
extremism uh be it far-right islamist in
cell or other and would she therefore
join me in supporting Amendment 43 to
ensure that by default this content is
hidden from all adult users yeah I I
completely support the comments of my
honorable friend and I'm so pleased to
see that she championed this cause in
the bill committee and we of course
support amendments 43 that there is
tables in my name of the colleagues in
the SMP to see that this toggle is on by
default because it is absolutely
abhorrent material that has been shared
and Amplified and that is the key Point
here Amplified online by these
algorithms by the processes and systems
in place and it is key that it is
obvious here that the government just do
not get this that being said there is a
majority in Parliament and in the
country for strengthening the Online
safety Bill and labor has always been on
the front foot arguing for a stronger
Bill since its first reading last year I
think it is important to also take this
opportunity to recognize the sheer
number of amendments and changes to this
bill and that we've seen so far indeed
even today Madam Deputy speaker we find
many more amendments to this bill tabled
by the government themselves
if this doesn't give an indication of
the mess that they have made of getting
this legislation over the line in a fit
and proper State I don't know what will
I have said it before and I am certain I
will say it again we need to be moving
forwards with this bill not to backwards
that is why despite a significant
government delay we will support it
receiving its third reading as each day
of inaction allows more and more harm to
spread online with this in mind Madam
Deputy speaker I too will make some
progress I will first address new Clause
1 tabled in the name of my honorable
friend The Honorable member for
Manchester Central and myself
colleagues will be aware that new Clause
1 is a very important addition to the
bill which will go some way to address
the gaps in the bill surrounding support
for individual complaints we on this
side of this house have repeatedly
queried ministers and the Secretary of
State on the mechanisms available for
individuals who may have appeals of
complaints and that is why new Clause 1
is so important it is vital that
platforms complaints procedures are fit
for purpose and this new Clause will
finally see the Secretary of State
publishing a report on the options
available to individuals we already know
that the bill in its current form is
failing to consider an appropriate
Avenue for individual complaints this
really is a classic case of David and
Goliath and it is about time that these
platforms go further in giving their
users a transparent effective complaints
process Madame Deputy speaker if it is
this issue and the substantial lack of
transparency that underpins so many of
the issues that labor has with the way
that the government have handled or
should I say mishandled this bill so far
and that is why the process by which the
government proceeded to remove all of
these all-important Clauses around legal
but harmful content in a quiet room on
committee Corridor just before Christmas
is even more frustrating this move put
the entire bill at risk important
sections which would have seen
Protections in place to prevent content
such as health and foreign State
disinformation content promoting
self-harm and disinformation and online
abuse and harassment from being actively
pushed and promoted towards them were
rapidly removed by this government and
it is not good enough that is why labor
have tabled a series of amendments
including new Clauses 4 5 6 and 7 which
we see as going some way to correcting
the government's extremely damaging
approach Madam Deputy speaker under the
terms of the bill as currently drafted
platforms could set whatever terms and
conditions they want and change them at
will we saw this with Elon musk's
takeover at Twitter when he rapidly
lifted the ban on cover disinformation
overnight just because of his own
personal views enabling new Clause 4 Our
intention is to ensure that platforms
aren't able to Simply avoid safety
duties by changing their terms and
conditions whenever they see fit this
group of amendments would give offcom
the power to set minimum standards for
platforms terms and conditions and the
power to direct platforms to change them
if they don't meet these standards
yeah I'll have to give up I'm very
grateful to my honorable friend and
she's making a really important Point
here she might not be aware but I've
raised recently in the house the case of
my constituents whose 11 year old
daughter was groomed on Spotify the
music streaming platform and was able to
upload explicit photographs of herself
on that platform her parents thankfully
found out and made several complaints to
Spotify who did not immediately remove
that content isn't that why we need that
Ombudsman I'm grateful for the
intervention I am aware of the case and
is truly appalling and truly shocking
and that is exactly why we need these
Protections in the bill to stop cases
like this from proliferating online to
stop the platforms from choosing their
own terms of service and to give offcome
as a regulator the real teeth in order
to take on these challenges
power to set minimum safety standards
based on the priority legal offenses
written onto the face of the bill that
cover almost all of the worst kind of
offenses from the child sexual
exploitation and citing violence racial
hatred and so on those are the minimum
safety standards that are set and the
bill guarantees it yeah
standards it's all of this horrendous
harmful content that I've described the
call for disinformation the harmful
State actors self-harm proliferation the
anti-Semitism that we're seeing online
misogyny this Intel culture all
proliferating online that is being
Amplified by the algorithms these
minimum set of State Standards can be
changed overnight yeah
foreign States disinformation is covered
because it's covered in the National
Security bill which will be part of the
priority offenses listed on the face so
those accounts can be disabled
everything that meets the criminal
threshold well everything that is well
that is in the bill there's The
Honorable lady knows that is in the bill
because it's in the National Security
Bill and that the criminal threshold for
all of those offenses that she lists are
set within schedule seven of the bill
itself yeah
yeah that that is just the problem
though isn't it a lot of these a lot of
these issues that are within the bill
that we are not would not be covered
within this minimum standards the
amendment that we are pushing today new
clause for they do not currently meet
the legal threshold and that is the
problem here this gray area of
incredibly harmful but legal content
that we're seeing proliferate online and
being Amplified by the algorithms being
Amplified by influencers for want of a
better word that is being fed to
everybody online and then they are being
shared incredibly widely and that is
what is causing harm and disinformation
but I won't give away one more time no I
need to make some progress here we've
got a lot to cover and a lot of
amendments as I've already outlined but
under the terms of the bill as I've said
these platforms can issue whatever
minimum standards they wish to and then
simply willfully change them overnight
so in tabling are close for it is Our
intention to ensure that the platforms
aren't able to avoid safety duties by
changing their terms and conditions and
this group of amendments as I said will
give offcom the relevant teeth in order
to act and to keep everybody safe online
and now we all recognize that this
legislation once enacted will be a
learning curve for everyone involved we
want to get this right and these
amendments will ensure that platforms
have specific duties upon them in order
to keep us safe this really is an
important point and I will continue to
make this clear every opportunity
because for far too long the platforms
and providers have got away with zero
regulation nothing whatsoever and enough
is enough
speaker during the last report stage I
made clear that labor considers
individual liability as Central to
ensuring Online safety is taken
seriously by online platforms we have
been calling for stronger criminal
sanctions for months and while we
welcome some movement on this issue from
the government today ultimately the
enforcement is now over a narrower set
of measures after the government gutted
much of the bill before Christmas this
last minute U-turn is another one to add
to the long long list but to be frank
Madame Deputy speaker very little
surprises me when it comes to this
government's approach to law making yeah
lady
um I I do have to say to her though to
describe this U-turn is not reasonable
as the government have interacted with
those who like her wanted to strengthen
the bill regularly there's been proper
engagement constructive conversation and
the government have been persuaded by
those who've made the similar case the
one she's making now I think that's
Warren's credit rather than criticize I
I completely disagree with the honorable
member because we actually voted on this
exact Amendment Before Christmas in the
previous report stage which was tabled
in my in the name of my friend the right
honorable member for barking and
dagenham and it was voted against it was
turned down word for word exactly the
same Amendment so if this is nothing but
a U-turn then what is it and Madam
speaker I am pleased to see a number of
important amendments as we've already
said today in the names of The Honorable
member for Abdi North and The Honorable
member for aquil and South perthshire in
particular I wish to draw a colleague's
attentions to new Clause 3 which
improves the child empowerment duties of
currently stand in the bill the
government may think that they are
talking a good game on child safety but
it is clear for all of us that there are
some alarming gaps remaining the new
Clause goes some way to ensuring that
the systems and processes behind
platforms will go further in keeping
children safe online in addition we are
pleased as I previously mentioned to
support Amendment 43 which calls for
this so-called safety toggle feature to
be turned on by default when the
government removed the Clause relating
to legal but harmful content during
committee they instead introduced a
requirement for platforms to give users
the tools to reduce likelihood of
certain content appearing on their feeds
now we have serious concerns about
whether this approach is even workable
but if this is the route the government
wish to take then we feel these tools
should at least be turned on by default
support
since she's on the the point around
safeguarding children will my honorable
friend be supporting uh the noble uh
baroness Kidron as the bill progresses
to the other house in ensuring that
coroners have access to data where they
suspect that social media may have been
played a part in the death of children
I can confirm we will be supporting
baroneska John and her efforts here we
are supporting a number of amendments
that are going to be tabled in that in
the Lords in the hope of strengthening
this bill further because we have
reached um the limit to where we can do
in this place and I I absolutely commend
the work of Vanessa John and the five
rights Foundation have been doing and to
support children and to make this bill
as safe as possible for everybody online
um but supporting Amendment 43 would
send a strong signal that our government
want to put Online safety at the
Forefront of all of our experiences when
using the internet and for that reason I
look forward to the minister seriously
considering this amendment going forward
and SNP colleagues can be assured as
I've previously outlined of our support
should there be a vote in that too more
broadly Madame Deputy speaker I would
like to highlight a series of amendments
table by myself and The Honorable member
for Manchester Central which ultimately
aims to reverse the damaging Avenue the
government have chosen to go down when
it comes to regulating so-called legal
and harmful but harmful content as I
have already mentioned the government
haphazardly chose to remove these
important Clauses during committee state
age the government have chopped and
changed this bill more times than any of
us can remember and we are now left with
a piece of legislation that is even more
difficult to follow and importantly
Implement than when we were than when it
was even first introduced Madam Deputy
speaker I think we can all recognize
that there is a huge amount of work to
be done in making this bill fit for
purpose labor have repeatedly worked to
make meaningful improvements at every
opportunity and it will be on the
government's hands if it is subject to
even more delay the minister knows this
and I sincerely hope he will take these
concerns seriously after all if you want
to listen to me then you would do well
to listen to the mountain concerns
raised by members on his own benches
instead
okay
talk talk
report on redress for individual
complaints
the question is that new Clause 1 be
read a second time
um I have noticed that there are some
people standing who I um who may not
have applied earlier if anyone is aware
of that if they could let me know so I
can adjust the timings accordingly at
the moment my estimate is that if
everybody was not longer than seven
minutes but it might be more like six
then we could get everybody in
comfortably without having to impose a
time limit pretty Patel
speaker and I Rise to speak very much to
um new Clause 2 which is the offense of
failing to comply with relevant Duty and
I do just want to pay tribute to my
honorable friends
um and write Tomball friends who have
championed new clothes to strengthen the
protections for children by introducing
criminal liability for senior managers
Madam Deputy speaker we've discussed
this issue already in the in this house
in the chamber but I do also want to
thank Charities and campaigners such as
nspcc for raising awareness and also for
being constructive and assiduous on this
and then of course the families the
families that have given Voice through
their own pain and suffering to really
give us influences to this issue and of
course if I may I'd like to thank the
front bench the minister and the
Secretary of State we've had
constructive dialogue it's fair to say
and they've listened to our concerns and
accepted that this issue had to be
addressed so as we debate this clause
and other aspects of this bill today I
think we should begin as we did last
time Adam Deputy speaker with our
thoughts on those who face tragedy and
distress as a result of accessing
inappropriate content online children
and vulnerable people have been failed
by tech companies and Regulation and of
course this is where we have that duty
to step up we have that responsibility
to tighten the law protect children from
online harms exploitation and
inappropriate content and of course that
has to be at the heart and center of lot
of the legislation not just through this
bill but also going forward and I think
again we've touched on the fact
throughout the various debates and I
know colleagues have been involved in
committee stage as well technology is
evolving and changing constantly and
with that of course we've got to keep on
building upon in size of course this
Clause does some simple and
straightforward things it makes senior
managers liable and open to being
prosecuted for failing to be proactive
in promoting and supporting the safety
duties in Clause 11 of the bill and as
it stands the provisions in the bill on
criminal liability fall short of what is
expected and required and criminal
liability for failing to comply with an
information notice from ofcom is welcome
ofcom have a very important role to play
I do not need to emphasize that anymore
but of course it does not go far enough
and that's where ministers have
obviously recognized this so I think
going forward we actually need to ensure
that all the flaws and failures are
sanctionable and the laws are changing
the right way and of course Madam Deputy
speaker it's not just the lawsuit this
particular government Department that's
leading this bill right now there's cuts
across other governments Apartments
we've touched on that many times before
and of course over 80 percent of the
public agree that senior Tech managers
should be held legally responsible to
prevent harm being caused to children on
social media I mean that's to us it's a
statement to be obvious when we've seen
such a borrowance and appalling harms
take place and around two-thirds report
to see managers prosecuted when failures
result in serious harm they'll call harm
can happen prior to an information
notice being issued by ofcom again we've
discussed that previously and we need to
see and the public need assurances that
these companies will have the Frameworks
and those safeguards to actually act
with responsibility and be held accounts
so that children are vulnerable and
vulnerable individuals are protect it so
this means meaningful actions not warm
words so this should mean that we have
proactivity in developing the software
the algorithms the technology to be
responsive and in short of course that
the measures are put in place to hold
people to account and the sanctions
cover including company law and
accountability and health and safety in
other areas Ireland has been mentioned
through the passage of this bill and
that's important and my colleagues who I
know will speak shortly as well have
always also touched on the similar
Provisions so it's right Madam Deputy
speaker that we put these measures in
place on the face of the bill for the
serious failures to protect children and
also I'm aware of course this is a
topical issue and in fact a number of
colleagues met with some of the tech
companies yesterday as did I
um and Tech UK that this gives us an
opportunity to raise the bar in the
United Kingdom so that technology
investment still comes forward that the
sector continues to grow and flourishes
in the right that way for the right
reasons and of course we want to see
that yes I would we'll give way
I thank you right on the lady for giving
way and clearly the issues of evolving
technology and holding people who can't
are hugely important can I make the
general point that digital uh education
could underpin all of these uh
safeguards if you like and that too
should be conducted in parallel digital
literacy teaching as with all the other
good efforts being made right throughout
our schools
Marvel friend is absolutely right and I
think no one in this house would
disagree with that and you know we have
to carry on learning in life and with
that it leads to technology other issues
as well but that applies to all of us
across the board for our young people
and having people in positions of
authority as well ensuring that the
right kind of information is also shared
to protect our young people but if I may
and I know the front bench will come on
to discuss this clause in more detail
shortly
um I would like to hear from the
minister my honorable friend the member
for Sutton team who's been so good
actually in engagement on this issue and
I would like to thank him personally
just for the proactive way in which he
spent time with all of us will we see
their Amendment prior to the bill going
to the other place for its second region
there and also for all colleagues
supporting the Clause 2
I think having an understanding around
the clear assurances that the provisions
we support
um and could have passed through this
house will not be diluted in the other
place by ministers I think that's
absolutely vital and ensuring we and we
should be discussing this today as well
what steps are the government and
off-com taking to secure the agreement
of the companies the tech companies to
work to ensure that senior managers are
committed to being proactive in meeting
their duties under Clause 11. now
recognizing a lot of things will flow
through secondary going forward but on
top of that as well the engagement with
the technoc company so that they can
prepare and be ready for that engagement
and they themselves know what duties
will be upon them is going to be
absolutely vital I think we also need to
know what further work is coming forward
in terms of guidance and regulation to
secure the delivery of clause 11 duties
and of course hold the companies to
account
so Madam Deputy speaking an interesting
time and I will just um shorten my
remarks now I trust and I hope that the
ministers will give those details I
think it's important for this debate and
discussion today before this moves into
the house of law to the other the other
place to give those assurances we need
to know that those protections will not
be diluted this is such a sensitive
issue and I think we've come a long way
and that's very much thanks to all
colleagues across both sides of the
house as well it is important that we
get the right outcomes because all of us
want to make sure that children are
protected from some Dreadful harms that
we've seen online
David Margaret Hodge thank you madam
Deputy speaker
um this is a really important piece of
legislation and it has taken as my the
front Branch said far too long to get to
the point that we find ourselves at
tonight it's been considered in a really
painstaking Way by members across the
house and write honorable members right
across the house and whilst today's
announcement that we will introduce
martinia manager and director liability
is most welcome the more recent
decisions to strip out vast chunks of
the bill Clauses that would have
contributed to making online a safe
place for us all those decisions
um I represent I think a tragic
opportunity missed by the government and
it will fall to the labor government to
put things right and I know from the
assurances given by our front bench that
they will do just that I don't want to
spend too much time on it but taking out
legal but harmful I have to talk a
little bit about the Jewish Community I
think the hope that the Online safety
bill would give us some respite from the
torrent of anti-Semitic abuse that some
of us have been subjected to that hope
has been thwarted the center for cut for
countering digital hate have conducted
research in this area and they found
that 9 out of 10 anti-semitic posts on
Facebook and Twitter
stay there despite requests to have them
removed an analysis by them of 714 posts
containing anti-jewish hate found that
they were viewed by more than 7.3
million people across the platforms 80
percent contained Holocaust denial and
70 percent identified as Neo-Nazi but
were not acted on although they were in
breach of the rules set by the platforms
people like me are left with a sense of
bitterness Madame Deputy speaker that
our suffering has to be tolerated
because of some ideological misplaced
flawed and Ill thought out
interpretation of freedom of speech
I want to move Madam speaker to the
amendment tabled by The Honorable member
of the stone and The Honorable lady
member for peniston and Stockbridge I
want to congratulate them for the work
that they have done in bringing this
forward and this and say to them I think
they would probably agree with me that
this should never have been an issue
that divided us as it did before
Christmas when I put forward a similar
Amendment it's not a party political
issue it's a common sense measure which
best serves both the national interest
and which will make online a safer place
for children I'm really pleased that the
two members The Honorable member of the
stone and the right honorable age of
beniston and Stockbridge have persuaded
their quality colleagues of the
justification I'm just sorry I wasn't
that successful but I am pleased that
the government has listened to them
the reason that this is important is the
following um explanation of Madame
Deputy speaker the business model that
is operated by platforms means that they
not just passively but actively
encourage abuse abusive content to
flourish online not only do they fail to
remove that contact but they actively
promote its inclusion through the
algorithms that they employ sadly
out of reading hateful harmful and
abusive content online the platform
companies and their senior managers know
that it's in their interest to encourage
maximum traffic on their platforms and
if this means letting people post post
and see vile abuse they will do it the
greater the traffic on these sites the
more attractive Things become to
advertisers and the more advertisers are
willing to pay for the posts for the ads
that they post on the site so the
platforms make money out of online abuse
the government originally wanted to deal
with this problem by funding the
companies but companies would simply
treat these fines as a cost to their
business businesses it wouldn't change
the model it that they have it would it
would add to the charges that they might
uh give to those who want to advertise
on their platforms but it would not
change the behavior of the platforms
furthermore we know that senior
directors owners and managers personally
take the decisions on the content they
may allow to appear on their platforms
and that their approach affects what
people post Elon musk's controversial
and aggressive takeover of Twitter where
he labeled sensible moderation of
content as a violation of freedom of
speech led to a 500 increase of in the
use of the n-word within 12 hours of his
acquisition telegram whose CEO is
Cavalry Roth has become the app of
choice of Terror networks like Isis
according to research conducted by the
Middle East media research institutes
yet when he was challenged about this
jurost refused to act on the
intelligence they provided to moderators
content saying we cannot make messaging
technology secure for everybody except
for terrorists so if senior managers
have responsibility for the content of
their platforms they have to be held to
account and we know Madame Deputy
speaker that holding the senior managers
to account will mean that online
businesses become a safer place for our
for our children Manu Deputy speaker we
have to decide whose side we're on are
we really putting the well-being of our
children first or are we putting the
interests of the platform first
everybody will of course claim that
we're putting the interests of children
first but if we are we have to put our
money where our mouths are and that
involves making the managers truly
accountable for what appears on their
platform we know that legislation
legislative director liability works
it's worked on health and safety and
construction sites it's worked in the
bribery act it's worked on tax evasion
and I hope to be moving similar
amendments when we come to consider the
issue of economic crime next week in
this house at the report stage of that
of that bill this is not simply a pure
Za in fact in fact the last thing we
want to do is to lock up a lot of
platform owners but it's a tool to
transform Behavior we won't be locking
up the tech Giants but we will be
ensuring that they moderate their
contact achieving this change Madame
Deputy speaker shows the house truly
working at its best cross-party focusing
on the merits of the argument rather
than playing Party politics with such a
serious issue I commend that particular
Clause to this house
Then Caroline dionage and just a
reminder about the um six minute
advisory time thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker it's a great relief to
see the Online safety Bill finally reach
this stage it seems like a really long
time since my right honorable friend the
member for Kenilworth and Southern
kicked this off with the ambitious aim
of making the UK the safest place in the
world to go online and while other
countries around the world had picked up
the edges of this we were truly the
first country in the world to set out
this kind of comprehensive Online safety
legislation since then other
jurisdictions have started and in some
cases concluded this work and in as one
of the relay of ministers who've carried
this particular baton of legislation on
it's a very long journey we are
tantalizingly close to getting to the
Finish Line with this it's why we need
to focus on that today and I'm really
grateful that the um the opposition
front bench have have confirmed that
they're going to support it at third
reading because we know that the
internet is magnificent and
life-changing in so many ways but the
dark Corners remain a serious concern in
particular to children but also to
schools of other vulnerable people and
of course the priorities of this film
must be to protect children to root out
illegal content and actually to hold the
online platforms to account to ensure
that they're actually doing what they
say they are doing when it comes to
dangerous content on their site so I do
warmly welcome the minister and the
Secretary of State's engagement on these
particular aspects of the bill and how
they've worked really hard to strengthen
it this legislation is so vital for our
children the nspcc have estimated that
more than 21
000 online child sex crimes have been
recorded by the police just in the time
that this legislation has been delayed
since last summer
I will
does she agree with me that the new
crime of cyber flashing is one instance
of how this bill has been improved which
should also help reduce some of the
violence against women and girls which
is a major issue of our time
he raised it because actually we do need
this piece of legislation to be future
proofed to deal with some of the really
recent emerging threats to women to
others uh that the online world has has
offered the Potential Threat of online
harms is everyday life for most children
in the modern world before Christmas I
received an email from my son's school
highlighting a tick tock challenge
encouraging children to strangle each
other until they passed out this
challenge probably didn't start on Tick
Tock it's um certainly isn't exclusive
to that platform but when my children
were born I literally never envisaged a
day when I would have to sit them down
and warm them about the potential
dangers of allowing someone else to
throttle them until they passed out it's
terrifying our children need this
legislation I welcome the government
support
um also for Amendment 84 to Clause 11 in
the name of my honorable friend the
member for Rutland in Melton to to ban
content which advertises so-called
conversion therapies for lgbtq plus
people your sexuality and who you love
is not something to be cured
unscrupulous Crooks should not be able
to prompt profit from pushing young
people towards potentially Sinister and
harmful treatments with regard to new
clothes 2 on senior executive liability
I really sympathize with the aims of
this amendment it's vital this regime
has the teeth to protect children and
hold companies to account I know the 10
maximum annual Global turnover and fines
is higher than some of the global
comparisons and certainly having clear
personal consequences for those
responsible for enforcing the law is an
incentive to do it properly but there is
a clear balance to strike we must make
sure that sanctions are proportionate
targeted and don't make the UK a less
attractive place to build a digital
business I'm really pleased to hear The
Minister's commitment to a final
Amendment which will strike this really
important balance I am concerned about
the removal of legal but harmful
measures I understand
complexity around defining them but
other measures in so including the
so-called triple Shield do not offer the
same protections for vulnerable adults
or avoid the cliff Edge when someone
reaches the age of 18 and this
particularly concerns me for
um for adults with special educational
needs or disabilities the key Point here
is that if the tragic cases of Molly
Russell and dozens of other young people
like her teach us anything it's at the
Dreadful harmful online content cannot
be defined strictly by what is illegal
because algorithms do not differentiate
between harmful and harmless content
they see a pattern and they exploit it
we often talk about the parallels
between the online and the offline world
we say that what's illegal online should
be illegal offline and vice versa but in
reality the two worlds are fundamentally
different in the real world if you're a
young person struggling with an eating
disorder or at risk of radicalization
your inner demons are not reinforced by
everyone you meet on the street but
algorithms are Echo Chambers they take
our fears and are paranoia and they
surround us with unhealthy voices that
normalize and validate them however
dangerous however hateful glamorizing
Eating Disorders accelerating extremist
racist anti-semitic views encouraging
violent misogyny on in cell sites
which is why I worry that the opt-out
option suggested in the build simply
doesn't offer enough protection the
lines between what's legal and illegal
are too opaque sadly it does feel like
this part of the bill has become the
lightning rod for those who think it
will result in an overly sensorious
approach
however we are where we are and as the
Molly Rose Foundation said the Swift
implementation of this bill must now be
the priority time's no longer on our
side while we perfect this vast
complicated and inherently imperfect
legislation the most unspeakable content
is allowed to proliferate in the online
world every single day I just finally
want to very quickly Madam Deputy
speaker put on record the exhaustive
efforts by the incredible team at dcms
and the home office who've brought this
piece of legislation to fruition if
there was ever an example of not letting
the enemy be the uh the the perfect be
the enemy of the good then this is it
because right now we need to get this
done the stakes in human terms simply
couldn't be any High fire
SNP spokesperson Kirsty Blackman thank
you very much my Madam speaker I'd like
to congratulate the member for a golf
sport on what was one of the very best
speeches I've heard on this bill and
we've heard quite a lot of speeches
um on on this bill it was it was
excellent very thoughtful and I want to
talk about a number of different
um amendments
um I'm not going to cover in any sort of
details the labor party's amendments
because
um as ever the labor front bench did an
excellent job in putting those forward
in the member from barking covered very
nicely and the amendment in relation to
liability and also
um brought up the the issue of heat
particularly when pointed towards the
Jewish community and I thank her for
consistently bringing this up I think
it's really important to hear her voice
and the voice of others um on on this
um I would like Madam speaker to move
Amendment 43 in my name and the name of
the member for
um uh Perth
um I can't remember to a title sorry
um it's been a long day
um in terms of amendment 43 that's about
the default toggle
um for
um uh unsafe material basically from
material that we agree we all agree this
material is unsafe we all agree this
material is harmful
um I think that um and the SNP think and
thankfully the labor party have said
that they agree with this amendment
um that we should have the safest option
should be the default option that's
where the point of view of which we
should start from we should start from
the point of view that if anybody wants
to see eating disorder content if they
want to see racist content that doesn't
meet the bar of illegality if they want
to see incredibly harmful content that
does not meet that bar they should have
to opt in to receive that content they
shouldn't see it by default they should
have to make that actual choice that
they want to see that content it is the
case and freedom of speech is written
into this bill it is the case that
people are able to to say whatever they
want to say in terms of as long as it's
below that illegal bar but we shouldn't
have to read it we should not have to
read the abuse that is pointed towards
minority groups and it should start from
the position of having that safest
option on it's intended we're trying to
improve the permissive approach that the
government's arrived at and it's a
simple change it's not controversial I
don't think requiring users to flip a
switch if they want to opt in to some of
the worst and most dangerous content
available online including pro-suicide
content pro-anorexia content bulimia
content rather than leaving it on by
default if the government is wanting the
terms and conditions to be the place
where
um the where things are um excluded or
included
um I also think that the platform should
have to say we are happy to have Pro
bulimia content we're happy to have
pro-anorexia content they should have to
make that abs absolutely clear and
explicit in the terms and conditions in
the terms of service that they have
rather than having to say we do not
allow X Y and Z and I think we should
have to be clear and upfront and honest
with people because then people would
know what they're signing up to and when
they sign up to um to websites um I want
to briefly mention um as well Amendment
44 which is in relation to Habit four
main features and we haven't spoken
enough about the Habit form in nature um
of social media particularly and if you
look at things like Tech talk and
Instagram if you look at Facebook if you
look at the way these are set up they're
set up to encourage and make you spend
time on that's how they make money they
make money by encouraging you to spend
as much time as possible on their site
that's the intention behind it and we
know modernity speaker that 42 of
respondents to survey by wrong young
minds reported displaying signs of
addiction like behavior when questioned
about their social media habits we know
that young people are worried about this
we know that they don't necessarily have
the tools to avoid that and that's why
and we put forward Amendment 44 in
relation to
um habit forming features in relation to
um actually taking this into account and
requiring platforms to consider this so
I think it's really important and new
Clause 3 was mentioned earlier in
relation to child user empowerment
there's a bizarre loophole in the bill
where it requires user empowerment
um toggles for adults but it doesn't
require them for children I mean it's
really odd that we do not require this
um for children when we know that
children are going to be able to see
um some of this content we know that
they're going to be able to access
features which are much more inherently
dangerous for children than they are for
adults that's why we put forward the
amendments in relation to private
messaging features and live streaming
features live streaming is a place where
self-generated child sex abuses shot
through the roof now if we have a
situation where with child user
empowerment children can choose
um or children could have to have to opt
in and they can have empowerment tools
to allow them opportunities to say no I
don't want to be involved in live
streaming or to allow their parents
opportunities to say no I don't want my
child to be able to live stream when
they sign up to Instagram I don't want
them to be able to share live photos and
be speaking to people that they don't
know that's why the private messaging
features amendment that we've put
forward allows children to say no I
don't want to get any private messages
from anyone that I don't know that they
should be able to do that it's not
written into the terms of service for
any of them it's not written into the
bill it's not written to the bill it's
one of the potentially harmful things
that there is that they should be able
to exclude themselves from having
conversations or any sort of
um just like you know if a child is
playing in a play park if we're talking
about the the
um relationship between real life and
the online world but child is playing in
a play park and some stranger comes up
and talks to them the child is perfectly
within the right I'm not speaking to
strangers my parents told me that and
this is a good idea not to speak to
strangers but they're not able to
exclude themselves from that in the
online world and that's why we're asking
for this to be taken into account that's
why we're asking for
um for platforms to to be encouraged to
switch off or to be able to switch off
private messaging live streaming
features for certain groups of people if
they were to switch them all for example
for children under 13
um on their platforms that would make
Roblox for example a far safer place
than it currently is
um I want also to talk about
um Amendment 84 in relation to
conversion therapy I'm very glad that
this amendment is in the bill and I'm
very glad to hear that there is moves by
the UK government in order to bring
forward the conversion therapy ban and
we've not yet that I'm aware of but I've
been in the chamber all day seen the
bill it's not yet been brought forward
and I'm told that it will be and I do
pay tribute to all of those people
who've worked really hard to get to the
position that this bill that the
government of agreed to bring this bill
forward and it you're to be commended on
that I'm very sorry it's taking this
long but I'm very glad that we are in
this position and I think this amendment
was massively helpful in that just
lastly on the Amendments and that we
have here I want to talk about the
amendment 50 which is in relation to the
risk of harm and this is still one of
the biggest issues that there are with
the bill is about the categorization of
platforms so the categorization of
platforms is on the basis of the size of
the platform and the the risk of the
features so the size of the platform is
the key thing the number of users that
there are on that platform is the key
thing it fails to take into account the
incredibly harmful very small platforms
that there are this amendment
um Amendment 50 is about giving offcome
the power to require platforms who are
incredibly harmful who are Intel forums
for example who are places like kiwi
Farms which are entirely set up in order
to Docs trans people and put their lives
at risk and it is about allowing ofcom
to say well we're going to put that as a
category one platform we are going to
require that it meets the category one
and rules that meets the risk
assessments that it does all of those
things that are required of category
because we should be asking these
platforms to answer for what they are
doing no matter how few members they
have on their on their social media
platform or whatever it is that they are
using no matter how small their user
base is one person being radicalized on
those platforms is one person too many
and this is not an extreme
um Amendment saying we should ban all
the things I mean I think probably
should but this is not an extreme
Amendment asking for that this is asking
for offcome to have a higher bar for
those platforms to require them to do
more on that so um management speaker
just just to finish
um I can't believe that we're here again
and I can't believe that this bill has
taken so long to get here I agree this
bill is far far from perfect but this
bill is better than nothing and that is
the reason that we will be supporter we
will not be voted against a third
reading because it is marginally better
than the situation we have to right now
so Jeremy writes thank you very much
Madam Deputy speaking speaker I I won't
say in passing I support amendments 52
and 53 my honorable friend for Stroud's
name and that of others I know she will
explain them very fully I don't need to
but they seem to me to be sensual
clarifications which I hope the
government will consider favorably I
want to focus though on new Clause 2 and
I have said before and I'm happy to
repeat that the individual criminal
liability provided for in this bill as
it stands is too limited attaching it to
information offenses only means that in
effect very bad behavior cannot be
penalized under the criminal law as long
as the perpetrator is prepared to
provide oftcom with information about it
that can't be sensible so I think that
there is a strong case for extending
criminal liability but I have to say I
think new Clause 2 goes too far there
are I think fundamentally two problems
with new clothes too the first is it's
drafted too broadly it would potentially
criminalize any breach of a safety Duty
under Clause 11
the Clause relating to children now we
all have called smart and Deputy speaker
think that keeping children safer online
is a core mission of this bill and I
hope that ministers will consider
favorably various other amendments which
might achieve that including amendments
in the name of the enable baroness
catron that The Honorable lady mentioned
earlier both in relation to coroners and
indeed in relation to all services
likely to be accessed by children but
Clause 11 covers a variety of different
duties including duties to incorporate
certain Provisions in terms of service
and to ensure terms of service are clear
and accessible now these are important
duties no doubt but I'm not convinced
that any and all failures to fulfill
them should result in criminal
prosecution I have to give away I just
thought I might mention to my right
overall friend about the written in the
serial statement which is now available
to the public which makes clear that
there are have been very useful this
constructive discussions taking in place
much of what he's saying is not
necessarily applicable to the State of
Affairs that we're now faced with
yes I'm grateful to my rival friend and
I'm coming to the ministerial statement
I accept what he says I think we are
heading in the right direction but since
new Clause 2 is at least before us at
the moment seemed to me I ought to
probably address it I hope in a helpful
way and I was going to say also that
there's nothing in the language of new
Clause 2 as it stands that requires a
breach of the duties to be serious or
even more than minimal and we should be
more discriminated than that the second
difficulty with the new clause which I
hope the government will pick up when it
looks again at this the difficulty of
Prosecuting successfully the sort of
offenses that we may create the more
substantive and fundamental child safety
duties in Clause 11 which are to
mitigate and manage the risk of harms
and to prevent children encountering
harmful content are expressed in terms
of the use of proportionate measures or
proportionate systems and processes and
the word proportionate is important and
describes the need for balanced
judgments to be made including of course
by taking into account freedom of
expression and privacy as required by
Clause 11 itself now aside from the
challenges of obtaining evidence of what
individual managers did or did not know
or do or say these balance judgments
could be very difficult for a prosecutor
to assess and to demonstrate to a
criminal court to the required standard
of proof where deliberately or
negligently wrong and the consequences
of that difficulty could either be but
it becomes apparent that these cases are
very hard to prosecute and therefore the
criminal liability isn't the deterrent
we hope for or that wide criminal
liability causes the sort of risk
aversion and excessive takedown of
material which worries I know my
honorable friend right one will friend
for stone and others who have supported
new Clause too so we need to calibrate
criminal liability appropriately
and I think it's also worth saying that
if we are to do this if we are to pursue
an extension of criminal liability I'm
not sure that I see the logic of
limiting that further criminal liability
only to breaches of the Child Safety
duties I can envisage some breaches of
safety duties in relation to Illegal
content that may also be deserving of
such liability which leads me on to
consider it exactly as my right one more
friend says how we might extend criminal
liability differently and I appreciate
the government will now be doing just
that perhaps the government can consider
doing so in relation to serious or
persistent breaches of the safety duties
rather than in relation to all breaches
of safety duties alternatively or
additionally it could look at individual
criminal liability for a failure to
comply with a confirmed notice of
contravention from ofcom and I work in
the direction of travel set out in the
written ministerial statement which
suggests that is where the government
May go and as the statement says the
recent Irish legislation which has been
prayed in hey does something very
similar and it's an approach that has
several advantages it's easier to prove
we will know if ofcom have issued a
notice requiring action to remedy a
deficient approach to safety duties and
we'll know whether ofcom believe it's
not been responded to adequately
and as of course we designed this new
system of regulation in this new era of
new regulation we should want open
conversations to take place between
regulator and regulated so it's how that
as to how best to counter these harms
anything that discourages platforms and
their directors from doing so may make
the system we're designing work less
well in promoting safety online and the
approach that I think the government
will now consider I think it's unlikely
to do that Adam Deputy speaker if you'll
forgive me let me say one final thing as
my right honorable friend for gosport
said I've been involved in the progress
of this bill almost from the start and
I'm delighted to see my right honorable
friend for maidenhead and whose
instruction I started doing it it's been
a tortuous progress no doubt to some
extent that was inevitable because of
the difficulty of this bill and the
territory we're seeking to legislate in
but I think the honorable lady who
speaks for the SNP for whom I have a
good deal of respect was probably a
little grudging suggesting that this
bill as it stands does only slightly
better than the status quo it does a lot
more than that and if as I hope we do we
send this bill to the other place this
evening and if the other places I know
it will will consider it again in some
thoroughness and seek to improve it
further then we will make the internet
not a safe place because I don't believe
that's achievable but a significantly
safer place and if we can do that it
will be the most important thing most of
us in this place have ever done
well things aren't going quite according
to plan
um so colleagues might like to gear
perhaps more to five minutes as we move
forward
um Luke Pollard thank you madam Deputy
speaker our way to speak in favor of new
Clause 4 on minimum uh standards and in
particular I want to restrict my marks
around minimum standards in respect of
in-cell culture now colleagues will know
of the tragedy that took place in
Plymouth in 2021 indeed the former Home
Secretary visited Plymouth to discuss
and meet people involved
um I really want to read the internet of
the disgusting festering in cell culture
that is capturing so many of our young
people and young men in particular in
particular I want minimum standards to
apply to make sure that on big and small
platforms where there's a risk that
minimum standard includes recognition of
in-cell content because at the moment
Intel content is festering in the
darkest corners of the internet where
young men are taught to channel their
fresh stations into an Insidious hatred
of women and taught to think of
themselves as brothers in arms in a war
against women it's that serious in
Parliament this morning I convened a
group of expert stakeholders to discuss
the dangers of in cell culture including
those from the center for countering
digital hate Tech against terrorism
moonshot girl guiding the anti-Semitism
policy trust and the internet watch
Foundation I believe that in-cell
culture is a growing threat online that
has real-world consequences and in cells
are targeting young men to swell their
numbers young people children to swallow
their numbers Andrew Tate may not
necessarily be an Intel but his type of
hate and division is growing and is very
popular online he's not the only one and
the model of social media distribution
that my colleague from barking spoke
about incentivizes hate to be viewed
shared and indulged in but this bill
doesn't remove Intel content online and
therefore it doesn't prevent potentially
future tragedies now as chair of the
all-party group on social media
um I won't see minimum standards to
raise the internet out of the sewer so
where is the compulsion for online
giants like Facebook and YouTube to
remove Intel content five of the most
popular Intel channels on YouTube have
racked up 140 000 subscribers and 24
million views between them YouTube is
still platforming four or five of them
why
how can these channels apparently pass
YouTube's terms and conditions the
content is truly hammering in these
YouTube videos men who have murdered
women are described as Saints lauded in
in cell culture we know in cells use
mainstream platforms like YouTube to
reel and unsuspecting young men called
normies before linking them to their own
small specialist websites showing
in-cell content this is called
breadcrumbing driving traffic from
audiences from mainstream platforms to
smaller platforms which will be outside
the scope of category 1 Provisions
therefore any minimum standards where
individuals can start their Journey
towards Intel radicalization I think we
need to talk less about freedom of
speech and more about freedom of reach
the ability for fewer and fewer people
to see that content to downrank sites
with appalling content like this to
increase the friction to reduce audience
reach Intel content not only includes
sexist misogynist content it frequently
also includes anti-semitic racist
homophobic and transphobic content
layered on top of one another but
without illegal and harmful provision it
means this bill does nothing to force
search engines to downright harmful
content if it's to be online it needs to
be harder and harder to point I don't
believe a toggle will be enough to deal
with this and I agree with Amendment 40
43 that if we are to have a toggle it
should be default on as as the norm a
toggle I believe won't work it will be
able to be evaded with a simple Google
Chrome extension that will Auto toggle
and therefore make it almost redundant
immediately it will be a minor
inconvenience not a game changer some
young men spend 10 hours a day looking
at Intel violent Intel content online do
we think a simple button a gdpr
annoyance button is going to stop them
from looking at this content it simply
won't and it won't stop future tragedies
and it's not just about other people
that this can affect it's also about the
increase in suicide one of the four
largest insult forms is dedicated to
suicide and self-harm suicide is
normalizing the form and called often
referred to as catching the bus this is
where people get together to share
practical advice about how they can take
their own lives this is not uh content
that we should be exposing our young
people to but it's currently legal it's
harmful but it's going to be legal under
this because the terms and conditions of
those sites are written by in cells to
promote in-cell content so yes it even
if those sites were moved from category
2 to category 1 they would still pass
the government's legislation because the
incels have written the terms and
conditions to allow that content so why
are smaller provision that smaller
platforms not included in this bill
ofcom should have the power to bring
Category 2 sites into scope if there is
a bait on the basis of risk
analysis by the center for countering
digital hate shows that on the largest
Intel website rape is mentioned in its
posts every 29 minutes with 89 of those
posts referring to rape in a positive
sense
50 of users post about child abuse on
the same site are supportive of
pedophilia and indeed the largest
in-cell form has recently changed its
terms and conditions to allow mention of
sexualization of pubescent miners unlike
prepubescent miners they make that
distinction it's disgusting and wrong
but why is that not covered in the bill
in front of us today I think there is a
real opportunity to look at Intel
content I'll be grateful if the minister
could meet again to discuss Intel
content with the cross-party group so we
can look at how we can make sure that
Intel content is harder and harder to
find online and ultimately removed
protecting all our young people from
going down this path
uh Damien Collins the speaker I'd also
like to always follow the excellent
speech by my right-handable friend the
member for Kenilworth and Southern
relating to new Clause 2 which I think
is a it's a new it was a new Clause I
had some sympathy with indeed The Joint
Committee of both houses that I chaired
proposed that there should be Criminal
liability for failure to meet the safety
Duty set out in the legislation and that
this should not just apply to child
safety measures but should apply to any
failing but I agree with my right
honorable friend that the new Clause has
drafted I think is too wide because if
it is saying that the liability exists
when the failure to meet the duties has
occurred what who is the determinant of
that that factor is that when offcom has
issued a notice is that when ofcom is
issued a fine is that when guidance has
been given that has not been followed
and what we wouldn't want to see is a
parallel judicial system
making different decisions to the
regulator in terms of when the safety
duties hadn't been met so I think the
idea of saying that when there is
persistent breach in the safety GCS when
companies have probably already been
fired and have been issued guidance when
they've been it's demonstrated they're
clearly in breach of the codes of
practice and they are refusing to abide
by them but I think that is where that
criminal liability should come in and
indeed similar Provisions already exist
in the gdpr legislation for companies
that are in persistent breach of their
duties and obligations and I think that
was a recommendation made by The Joint
Committee of both houses that should be
included in the bill in some ways
throughout the Journey of this
legislation the inclusion of criminal
liability has been something that has
been consistently strengthened in the
draft bill when it was published there
was no immediate commencement of any
criminal liability even for not
complying with the information notices
given by ofcom that was included when
the bill was presented the second
reading I'm pleased that the government
is now going to consider how we can
correctly Define the failure to meet the
safety duties would be remember what the
criminal sanction that go with them
would be as well because then that will
be an important measure for companies
that are in serial breach of their
duties and obligations and have no
desire to comply I also think this issue
is is relevant and linked to The Wider
debate around legal but harmful that
we've had today and the the recommittal
committee because if we're going to have
criminal sanctions non-compliance we
need to be really clear what this
company is supposed to do it needs to be
really clear to them what they need to
do as well and this is why when the
Joint Committee produced its report that
we recommended that the illegal but
harmful Provisions in the bill should be
changed because they don't do what many
people in this in the house have
asserted that they do do which is set
standards and requirements for companies
to remove legal content they were never
there to do that they provided risk
assessment for a wider range of content
but may have been helpful but it didn't
require the removal of content that
wasn't wasn't either a breach of the
community standards of the platform or a
breach of the legal threshold the
changes to the ability to be made help
in some ways the idea of having criminal
liability because written onto the face
of the bill are the offenses that are
within scope what they have to do and
also the requirement they have to
enforce their own terms of service where
therefore the safety standards aren't
defined by law but defined by the
platform now I think the safety
standards are important and there is a
danger sometimes in this debate we
pretend that they don't really exist and
it's understandable why we do that
because the companies aren't very good
at enforcing them you know they're not
very good at doing the things they say
they will do in fact I go back to the
the police to hear as a former board
member of the center for counter and
digital hate that organization cited so
often in this debate but I go back to
the evidence their chief executive gave
to the Joint Committee where he said if
the one thing they could do is enforce
their own terms of service if we had the
legal power to make them do that many of
the problems we're discussing would go
away so that is a very very important
sanction and I think on the point around
the smaller platforms I think in reality
ofcom have the power to enforce safety
standards at the level setting the bill
on any platform of any size the question
of saying someone the platforms out of
scope well they can only take
enforcement based on the terms of
service and platforms like that are very
likely to have very very weak terms of
service or practically non-existent ones
which is why having the minimum safety
standards based on the law is so
important and we'll just briefly like to
touch on the time I have left just
regards to advertising my honorable
friend because it's obviously labor
remember Dover has an amendment relating
to immigration offenses that are
promoted for advertising and indeed the
the additional Amendment the government
is accepting relating to advertising in
in Banning promotional conversion
therapy is important indeed I'm very
grateful to manual friend for giving
away and particularly because it's
referenced the proposals that my
honorable from the member for Dover
that's made I have also had discussions
and I am grateful to the minister and
the Secretary of State the discussions
they've had with me on making modern
slavery a specific priority offense as
well as illegal immigration I think this
is very important
um I agree with my honorable friend I
think that is and that is exactly right
and I think it is right as well we look
at including additional offenses by
including them on the face of the Berlin
schedule seven as offenses uh that will
be considered as part of the legislation
but as as where this touches advertising
the government already accepted uh
following the recommendations joint
committee that the promotion of frauds
should be uh should be regulated in the
bill even if it's in advertising there
are other aspects of this too modern
slavery is one immigration princes is
another well I think we need to we need
to now move that pace to close this
loophole where the consideration was to
be given for advertising outside of the
bill but through the online advertising
review the principle has already been
accepted that the illegal activity is
promoted through an advert on an online
platform should be regulated as well as
if it was an organic posting yet that
General provision doesn't yet exist and
I think in considering these additional
amendments as the government has done
which is the right thing to do I think
the government also needs now to look at
the general presumption that any illegal
activity that is a breach of the safety
duties is included and will be regulated
and that if someone includes an advert
it doesn't become exempt whereas we're
regulated if it was an organic posting
thank you
thank you uh thank you madam depson
speaker
I would like to focus on new Clause one
dealing with redress new Clause 43 the
toggle default uh new Clause 4 on
minimum standards
Madam Deputy speaker this bill is a very
important piece of legislation however
I'm afraid that it has been seriously
watered down by the government and in
particular uh it's been seriously
weakened by the removal of measures to
tackle legal but harmful content
I do acknowledge that some progress has
been made recently now that the
government has accepted the need for
criminal sanctions for senior managers
of tech companies however there are
still many gaps in the bill and I want
to deal with some of those in the time
available to me tonight
um before I do so Madam Deputy spook I
would like to pay tribute to the
families who've lost children due to
issues related to social media and some
of those families are in the public
Gallery tonight in particular I want to
mention the Stevens Family for my
constituency of reading East 13 year old
Ollie Stevens from my constituency was
murdered in a horrific attack following
a plot which is hatched on social media
the two boys who attacked Ollie had both
shared dozens of images of knives online
and they used 11 different social media
platforms to do this sadly none of those
platforms took this content down and
that is why the matters we're talking
about are so important to all of us in
our community
Madam Deputy speaker following this
awful case
um I want to support a number of the new
Clauses these I believe will make a
significant change lead to a significant
change in the law which I hope will
prevent any similar tragedy happening
again
focusing on new Clause one I I would
like to stress the importance of this
clause which I believe will help parents
to make complaints as Ollie's dad
Stewart often says
uh you can you simply cannot contact the
tech companies you send an email and you
get no reply
it is important to tackle this matter
and I do believe that new Clause will go
somewhere to doing that turning to new
Clause 43 as mentioned by other speakers
surely it makes sense for parents to
know that there is some protection for
their children from harmful content
and the Clause would provide some real
reassurance with a default position of
protecting children I would urge members
from across the house here tonight to
support this clause
Madam Deputy speaker I would add because
I believe that both children and
vulnerable adults should be better
protected from legal but harmful content
and further action should be taken the
Clause does at least take away does at
least make some clear steps in this
direction
I am very aware of time and there are
many other important new Clauses which I
would like to support tonight and I
would just like to reiterate my uh
support and backing for my front bench
colleague uh The Honorable member for
pontyprid and to thank you madam Deputy
speaker for the opportunity to
contribute tonight
human Deputy speaker and it's a pleasure
to follow the honorable gentleman and I
congratulate him for his moving tribute
to his constituent son that's a really
terrible story
Madam Deputy speaker this bill will be
life-changing for many but it's also I'm
sorry to say taken far too long to get
to this point the government promised in
2015 to end children's exposure to
harmful online material and then in 2017
committed to making the UK the safest
place for children to be online and as I
waited this morning in the freezing cold
on the station platform for a train that
was late a fellow passenger spoke to me
about the bill he said how happy he was
that action is at last underway to
protect children from the dangers of the
internet as a father of three young
children he told me it's one of his
greatest concerns
and I'm afraid that at the moment the
internet is as Lawless as was the wild
west and children are viewing images of
abuse addiction and self-harm on a daily
basis
as others have said the stats are
shocking around three and a half
thousand online child sex offenses are
recorded by police on a monthly basis
and every month over a million UK
children access online pornography
and Madam Deputy speaker it's been said
that if you join certain popular social
media Platforms in the time it takes to
make a cup of tea you will have been
introduced to suicidal content go on
just kill yourself you know you want to
so I'm incredibly proud that our
government is bringing forward a bill
that will change lives for the better
and I hope and expect it will be a Best
in Class for other governments to do
likewise and I want to pay tribute to my
right honorable friend the member for
Chippenham as well as her predecessors
for their ruthless focus on making the
online World a safer place at the end of
the day improving lives is what every MP
is here to do and across this house we
should take great Delight that at last
this bill will have its remaining common
stages today
I also want to pay tribute to my
honorable friends the members for
peniston and stocksbridge and for stone
for their determination to give the bill
even more teeth and I want to sincerely
thank the Secretary of State for her
willingness to listen but not only that
to take action
so new Clause 2 brought forward by my
honorable friends will not now be moved
because the secretary of state has
agreed to bring forward a government
amendment when the bill goes to the
other place
what new Clause 2 sought to achieve was
to create a backstop so if a senior
manager in a tech firm knowingly allows
harm to be caused to a child which
results in for example their abuse or
suicide that manager should be held
accountable and a criminal prosecution
with up to two years in prison should
follow
now I fully appreciate that there are
many in the tech world who say first of
all that this will discourage people
from taking on new senior roles and
secondly that it will discourage inward
investment in the tech sector in the UK
Madam Deputy speaker these are very
serious concerns and deserve to be
properly addressed
first with regard to the potential for
senior textile to be unwilling to take
on new roles where there is this
accountability I would argue that my own
experience as City minister in 2015 can
provide a good example of why this is an
unnecessary concern then we were seeking
to address the aftermath of the 2008
financial crisis and we established the
possibility of criminal liability for
senior financial services staff
it was argued at the time that this
would be incredibly damaging to UK
financial services and that people would
be unwilling to take on directorships
and Senior risk roles well I think we
can all see clearly that those concerns
were unfounded
some might even say well Tech firms
would say that wouldn't they
in my view Madam Deputy speaker the
likelihood of a criminal prosecution
will always be low but the key
difference is that in the future Tech
managers instead of waking up each day
thinking only about business targets
will wake up thinking have I done enough
to protect children as I meet my
business targets and that I'm sure we
can agree would be a very good thing
secondly there are those that argue that
inward investment to the UK's Tech
sector could be killed off and that
would indeed be a concern the UK Tech
sector leads in Europe and at the end of
22 retained its position as the main
Challenger to the U.S and China
fast-growing UK tech companies have
continued to raise near-record levels of
investment more than France and Germany
combined the sector employs 3 million
people across the UK and continues to
thrive so it's absolutely right that
ministers take seriously the concerns of
these major employers
however I think we can look to Ireland
as a good example of a successful Tech
Hub where investment is not stopped as a
result of strong accountability laws the
Irish Online safety and media regulation
Act passed in 2022 carries a similar
criminal responsibility to the one
proposed in new Clause 2 yet Ireland
remains a successful Tech Hub in the
European Union
of course I'm going for my girlfriend
friend she's she's dispelling all these
scare stories quite rightly which we've
we've heard one of the briefs we had
warned that if this new Clause 2 would
go through it portends the use of upload
filters where the system sweeps in and
removes content before it has been
posted well that will be a good thing
wouldn't it because we need these social
media companies to be investing in more
moderators to be more aware of the
harmful stuff before it goes online and
starts to do the damage to actually lead
to more investment but in the right part
of the employees of these social media
companies where Facebook meters it now
it's made 39 billion dollars profit in
2021 it's not short of money to do that
are they
well I think my honorable friend makes a
very good point and of course as I've
said the reality is that those Tech
managers waking up trying to meet
business targets will now look at
meeting them in a way that also protects
children and that is a good thing Madam
Deputy speaker I think we will look back
on this period since the real rise of
social media and we will simply not be
able to believe what millions of
children have been subjected to every
single day as the government special
advisor on early years it seems to me
that all the work we're doing to give
every baby the best start for life will
be in vain if we then subject them
during their vulnerable childhood years
to the Daily onslaught of appalling
vitriol violence abuse and sordid
pornography that is happening right now
it's little wonder that the mental
health of young people is so poor so
it's my hope that this bill will truly
support our attempts to build back
better after the covid lockdown the
government's clear commitment to
families and children and the prime
minister's own personal commitment to
the vision for the best start for life
is apparent for all to see and keeping
children safe online will make a radical
Improvement to all their lives thank you
in order to ensure that we get everybody
in I'm going to introduce a five-minute
time limit Richard Bergen thank you
madam Deputy speaker I've listened with
interest to all the powerful speeches
that have been made but the problem is
that
well but when legislation moves through
Parliament it's meant to be improved
during its Passage through Parliament
the great pity is that this bill has got
worse not better as it's proceeded
through Parliament it's a real tragedy
that the bill has watered down measures
protecting adults from harmful but legal
content so I'm rising to speak against
uh the Amendments which have come from
the government including 11 to 14 and 18
and 19 which relate to the removal of
adult safety duties I'm also speaking in
favor of amendments including new Clause
4 from the labor front bench and also
Amendment 43 from the SNP which go at
least some of the way to protect adults
from harmful but legal content and the
reason that I'm Keen to raise these
points today is because of a tragic case
happened in my constituency which I've
raised in the house on more than one
occasion Joe Hill a popular young former
Army Cadet in my constituency was aged
just 23 when he took his own life after
accessing dangerous suicide related
content on harm as I mentioned before
his mother Catherine and his
sister-in-law Melanie have run a
courageous campaign to try to ensure
that when this legislation becomes law
what happened to Joe doesn't happen to
people in the future now for much of the
passage of the bill I'd been hardened
speaking to the predecessor of the
current front bench of the government it
felt that we were maybe not as quickly
as we would like but going in the right
direction but the government amendments
mean that we're now going in the wrong
direction and I can tell you that Joe's
mother Joe's sister-in-law a heartbroken
at the direction of travel the
government currently has on this bill in
relation to protecting adults from
harmful but legal content so I urge the
minister I urge the minister to think
again because government Amendments have
gutted harmful but legal protections for
adults Reckless amendments meaning sites
will not even have to consider the risk
that harmful but legal content poses to
adult users on their platform as I say
bills are meant to get better as you go
through Parliament with the government's
amendments we've seen the Opposites and
a key statistic is research from the
Samaritan show that just 16 percent of
people think that access to potentially
harmful content on the internet should
only be restricted for children as I say
my constituent Joe was 23 we all know
that it's just
false to presume that people stop
becoming vulnerable at the age of 18.
there's so many vulnerable adults in our
society and people of course who become
vulnerable when they see these things
online when they're dragged down this
online Rabbit Hole of dangerous harmful
content so the importance of including
harmful but legal content is clear
content content is legal but undoubtedly
harmful includes information
instructions and advice on methods of
self-harm and suicide content that
portrays self-harm and suicide is
desirable and crudely removing
protections from harmful content 18
years of age leaves vulnerable people
exposed to potentially fatal content and
we've heard today individual filters are
simply not enough to protect vulnerable
people because the government set out
this up to individuals to filter legal
but harmful sense but often people
experiencing Suicidal Thoughts will
actually look for ways to take their own
life and actually seek out harmful
content so in conclusion the truth is
that the government has ignored the real
world expertise of groups like The
Samaritans and others in order in order
to put the interest out to say of tech
Giants first and those on the Tory back
benches who put so-called freedom of
speech so-called freedom of speech ahead
of the safety of people like Joe from my
constituency who took his own life at
the age of 23 years of age and I hope to
see further work on this bill in the
other place to ensure that vulnerable
adults are given the protection they
deserve that was my constituent Joe's
parting wish in the letter he left
today's family that what happened to him
wouldn't happen to others let's not lose
this opportunity let's improve this bill
and I think the other place has a vital
role to imply to play and ensuring that
this bill improves and protects
everybody
so John Hayes okay one of the most
notable changes in my lifetime Mr Deputy
speaker has been the department of
debasement of public discourse the
internet a place for posturing preening
and posing but rarely for January
discussion or measured debates must take
much of the blame for this
transformative decline but while the
coarsening of the national conversation
is among the most obvious examples of
harm being done with the Internet it's
merely the tip of a very dangerous
Facebook
Beyond every superficial banality looks
a growing crisis of depression Decay
misery and malaise of self-doubt and
self-harm all of which are facilitated
by tech companies that profit from
exploiting insecurities doubts and fears
tech companies do not exist simply to
facilitate communication rather control
and manipulate virtual interaction in
ways that play on innate fears the
social media conglomerates entire
business model relies on ruthlessly
exploiting vast quantities of data
harvested from their users
driven by nothing Beyond profit and
growth they've abandoned any notion of
Duty of care because their business
model depends on monetarizing
information with little regard to how
it's generated or how it's used even
when death puts children at deadly risk
perhaps this world for ignorance is why
social media consistently fails to
police videos advertising glamorizing
illegal Channel Crossings the 1400
miners accompany the nearly 50 000
Crossing last year have their images
placed on the internet as poster
children for this despicable trade and
I'm delighted that the uh work done by
my honorable friendly man for Dover and
her and then now accepted by the
government will begin to address that
particular wickedness
the amendment now wisely accepted with
the government will wipe such material
from the internet requiring social media
companies to face up to their face up to
their responsibilities implying this
evil trade
if drafts are correct care this bill is
an opportunity for Britain to lead the
way in curbing the specious Sinister
Spike from excesses the internet age
because for all of that virtual assembly
the tech Giants lack of action speaks
louder than words
the most facilitating promotion of
deadly Channel Crossings or the
day-to-day Damage Done to the mental
health of Britain's young people let us
be under No Illusion those the top know
exactly the harm they reap whistle vein
leaks by Francis Hogan last year
revealed and Mr Zuckerberg's matter as a
com is a company fully aware of the
damage it does for the mental health of
young people a new face of their
inaction nude Clause 2 led by my right
or friendful stone and my honorable
friend the penicillin Stockbridge I
please and proud to support them in
doing so makes Tech directors personally
legally liable for brooches of their
child's safety duties no longer will
these senior managers be able to wash
their hands the harm they do
and no longer with the way to perpetuate
these Sinister algorithms which which ra
which rather than merely reflecting harm
cause harm
strengthen the powers of off come to
enforce these duties will ensure the
buck stops with tech management
like the American frontier of Legend the
virtual world of the internet Can Be
Tamed the Beast can be caged there's a
GK Chesterton said unless a man becomes
the enemy of evil he will not just
become its slave but rather his champion
the greedy careless Tech conglomerates
cannot be trusted to track themselves
this bill is a welcome start but in time
to come as a social media Beast rides
and breathes Parliament will need to
take whatever action is necessary to
protect our citizens and to quench its
fearful fire yeah
sir Deputy speaker
first and foremost as we approach to the
remaining stairs of this bill we must
remember the importance of it we as MPS
hear stories of the dangers of online
harms and and that some wouldn't believe
I think it's fair to say that uh two
that those in my generation were very
fortunate to grow up in a world where
social media didn't exist it just said
that founded it a few minutes ago and
I'm really glad that I didn't have to go
through it it's so accessible nowadays
and children are being socialized in
this environment so it's imperative we
do all we can to ensure that if this is
the case they are particularly looked
after
um can I take a moment to discuss the
importance of new clothes too and and
and there have been many ongoing
discussions regarding who the responsive
lives with when it comes to the
regulation of online harms new clothes
too with ultimately making an offense
for service providers not to comply with
their safety duties of protecting
children none of a member for pedestal
and Stockbridge has describe the world
of social media as a modern Wild West
and Lawless implementary environment how
true those words are so I want to put on
record my thanks to the honorable lady
and also to the right honorable member
for stone for all of their Endeavors to
deliver change and boost the members
have been successful and to them well
done
some three and a half thousand online
third sex offenses are recorded by the
police each month each uh each uh each
month 1.4 million UK children access
online porn the majority which is
degrading abusive and violent the bill
does currently not hold text bosses and
they would say liable for their own
failures and child and Public Safety
this Clause must be supported the day
and I'm very very pleased the government
has made it to accept them
fines or something or not not enough and
if we feel the addresses in today's
build uh that this house are liable
because senior Tech bosses bosses seem
not to be I I do and I'm of a mind and
my party is as well to support new
clothes for uh put forward by our
position and listen to saver uh safety
juries protecting adults and Society
minimum standards per terms of service a
new closet is also one of importance and
I make this comment
um over the last couple of years my
office has been received up numerous uh
stories from parents who have witnessed
their children dealing with the
consequences of what an eating disorder
can do I have a very close friend whose
daughter a 16 year old is experiencing
that at a moment as a real
um hard on the family and everyone the
social media pages are just brutal I've
heard of tick tock Pages which glorify
bulimia and anorexia both have been told
of Instagram pages that provide tips for
self-harm which are also horrendous
what's important here is that the if we
cannot pick and choose what forms of
harm should be written as build it isn't
fair that some forms of harm are
addressed under this bill and someone
refer to the offcome and some are just
ignored communication and engagement
with third-party stakeholders is the way
to to tackle us and deal with it for
example if we take a social media page
that has been started to comment on
eating disorders and is generally unsafe
and unhelpful to young people struggling
this should be flied and handed over to
Health Care Professionals TPS nurses
those who know best and if we can do
that within this uh Online safety
building I believe it's a step in the
right direction
on balance we all get harmful content
should be reserved for regulations and
formed by proper stakeholder engagement
um just to touch very very briefly uh Mr
Debbie speaker on new Clause 3 this
would provide a required providers to
include features which child users may
use or apply if they wish to increase
their control over harmful content this
is currently restricted to the adults
once we understand the need to impart
these and those young people who to be
responsible and acknowledgeable and
offer the decisions that they make we
are able to recognize the value of
targeting this duty at adults many of
them do do hold the parental
responsibility very very close to their
heart more often enough and enough this
is just an important as the regulation
uh to conclude Mr Deputy speaker we we
have seen too many suicides too much
danger emerges from online and social
media social media has the potential to
be an educational and accessible space
for all including young people however
the safety precautions must be there for
the sake of the young people who can so
very easily follow the trough somewhere
all aware of enrolled my own consistency
where we've had a spirit of of suicides
uh and young people especially the young
people seems to be a click of friends
and it really quite worries me it's all
about regulation and ensuring harmful
content is dealt with and removed the
correct and informed individuals are
making the decisions around what is safe
and what is not so I have faith in in
the minister and government in this bill
that I will EMT address the outstanding
issues it doesn't stop every evil that
there is online but what it does do as
the element uh said at the back and
makes it safer and if it makes it safer
than Mr W speaker then I think it's one
that we we could really look towards um
uh to supporting and it really is truly
good news thank you
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and if I may
say so it's a pleasure to see my East
Kent neighbor in the chair today I would
like to speak to the amendment 82 in my
name his Deputy speaker and also in
support of new Clause 2 and amendment
83. I spoke at summer length in the last
report stage on an Associated Amendment
and I'm conscious there is a lot of
interest in speaking tonight so I'll
keep my comments brief I'm grateful to
the many right honorable and honorable
friends who supported my Amendment those
named on the face of it and otherwise
and in particular I would like to thank
my right honorable friend the member for
South Holland and the deepings for his
considerable assistance in securing uh
changes going forward
Amendment 82 sets out a requirement to
remove content that may result in
serious harm or death to a child while
crossing the English Channel in small
boats Mrs Deputy speaker the risk of
harm or death in the channel Crossings
is very real
four children have drowned in the last
15 months with many many more harmed
with exposure to petrol and salt water
Burns and put it danger here and abroad
by organized crime and people
traffickers
social media is playing a direct role in
this criminal Enterprise it must be
brought to book and the videos and other
content that encourage such activity
must be taken down
there is an obligation on us to protect
children especially lone children who
find themselves not in the protection of
Social Services either here or abroad
but in the hands of evil people smuggles
and people traffickers
Mr Deputy speaker I hope that whatever
our differences may be across this house
in terms of how open or otherwise our
borders and migration system should be
we should be United in compassion and
concern and Action for Children and
young people in the snap of this wicked
criminal activity that is what my
Amendment 82 seeks to do
turning briefly to other amendments and
first in new Clause 2 which seeks to
hold senior managers to account
I'm very grateful to the work of the
right honorable my retinol friend for
stone and my honorable friend for
peniston and stocksbridge for that
excellent work on this but I was
somewhat disappointed to read the
comments which have been repeated by The
Honorable member for pontyprus that it's
some kind of weakness for government to
agree amendments and I particularly
wanted to comment on that in relation to
this new clause 2.
because in my deciding to support new
calls too I was very persuaded by the
remarks of the right honorable lady for
barking at the last report stage and I'm
grateful to her for the strength of her
comments and persuasive nature of that
it is our job here in this house to make
sure that we consider and make
responsible amendments and that's what I
think on this side of the house we have
sought to do so I'm very pleased that
the government has moved in relation to
new Clause 2 and I think it is really
important to recognize that it shows a
confidence and strength of leadership in
the Prime Minister and his ministers the
culture secretary and those ministers in
her department and in the home office as
well as the solicitor general that they
will work with us to ensure that this
legislation is stronger yet yeah yeah
and then finally if I may just turn to
Amendment 83 in the same spirit
I was very moved by the personal account
and the comments made by my right
honorable friend for
um Cheltenham in
um Chelmsford in uh in the report stage
and that again is why I lent my support
to her amendment I think she has made a
powerful case
that it is important to protect children
but also to recognize as comments have
been made that as children turn 18
they may still be extremely vulnerable
in the need of support
so I thank her for that and I know a
number of members feel likewise
so in conclusion I thank the culture
secretary and the minister for their
engagement to date for their commitment
that's been made in the written
ministerial statement to strengthen the
bill in relation to the prevention of
modern slavery and illegal immigration
including for the protection of children
and on that basis I confirm I will not
be moving Amendment 82 later today thank
you so William cash thank you very much
Mr Deputy speaker
in a nutshell we must be able to
threaten Tech bosses with jail there is
precedence for this jail sentences for
senior managers in a great range of UK
legislation are commonplace for breaches
of Duties that is absolutely and
completely clear
and the shadow for the former Shadow
attorney general I know exactly what the
law is on the subject I can say this the
protection of our children and
grandchildren from predatory platforms
for financial gain on the internet which
is endemic throughout the world and in
the UK
inducing suicide self-harm and sexual
abuse is an assault on the mind of our
young children and on those who are
affected by it and the families who are
affected by it like Ian Russell Ian
Russell has shown great courage in
coming out with his tragedy of his small
child 14 years old committed suicide as
a result of the Corolla made clear of
these activities it is Unthinkable that
we will not deal with it and we are
dealing with it now and I thank the
Secretary of State and I thank the
minister for responding with
constructive dialogue in a very short
space of time since we really got to
grips with this and can I say this the
written ministerial statement is
absolutely crystal clear it says where
senior managers or those purporting to
act in that capacity have consented or
connived in ignoring enforceable
requirements risking a serious home to
Children the criminal penalties
including imprisonment and fines will be
commenced to similar offenses and if you
make a comparison as a Ensemble lady for
barking and for barking and dagenham
made clear there are Financial penalties
in the financial services that is
international as well and there is also
the construction industry as my right
normal friend my honorable friend the
member for peniston Stockbridge has said
the fact is that these are already on
our statute book so I don't care what
the European Union's doing in its
legislation and I'm glad to know that
the Irish legislation which has been
passed and is an act has been through
all these different uh permutations and
examinations and they've come up with
something which also includes similar
severe penalties it can be done but this
is our legis station in this house and
we will do it the way we want to do it
to protect our children and our families
and I'm just about Fed Up of listening
to all the mealy mouth remarks coming
from those who say we can't do it it's
not quite appropriate
I'd say to hell with that we're talking
about our children and I'll say this too
when it comes to the question of past
record I just mentioned this
in
1977-78 a great friend of mine several
Townsend the member for bexleyheath
brought forward the first protection of
Children built and he asked me to help
him and I did and we got it through it
was incredibly it was incredibly
difficult at the time you have no idea
Mr Deputy speaker how much resistance
was put up by certain members of this
house in getting it through including
ministers and I can tell you it was Jim
Callaghan I spoke to him because I was
here I've been here so long and I be he
I was here when Jim Cannon was in the
house after he'd been prime minister
and I said how did you give it so much
time so that we could get the bill
through oh he said it's very simple he
said I was sitting in bed with my wife
in the in number 10 in the flat upstairs
and she wasn't talking to me and I said
what's wrong darling and she's he said
she had replied to him if you don't get
that protection of children pill through
I won't speak to you for six months
and it went through so there you go so
there's a message there for all
secretaries of state and even for prime
ministers I did raise this with the
prime minister in December on the
question of uh on the liaison committee
I I invited him to consider it and I'm
so glad that we've come to this after a
very constructive discussion and
dialogue it needed it it isn't a matter
of Chariots of Fire it's a quest of
Chariots on fire because we've done all
this in three weeks and I can only say
it's an extremely grateful for the hunt
for the 51 MPS who stood firm because we
know the realities of this house I have
to say it having been involved in one or
two show and see discussions in the past
but it's only when you've got the
numbers but the results start to come as
a rule but I want to pay tribute to them
to the ministers for their constructive
dialogue and I think the Irish example
will provide a model but it will be our
legislation it will be modeled on some
of the things that they have already
enacted but it's not just simply a
matter of their legislation being
transformed into ours it will be our
legislation and in the European
Parliament in in the European Parliament
I know I just want to say this
Miriam Kate
your criminal liability to the Online
safety bill but as my honorable friend
has has so clearly set out we won't be
pushing it to the vote as a result of
the very welcome commitments that have
been made by the minister to introducing
a similar amendment in The Other Place
Mr Deputy speaker protecting children is
not just the role of parents but the
responsibility of the whole of society
including our institutions and
businesses who wish to trade here and
that is the primary aim of this bill
which I wholeheartedly support to keep
children safe online from horrendous
harms many of which unspeakably have
been mentioned by my right honorable
friendly member for northamptonshire we
look back in horror at children being
forced to work down lines or neglected
in Victorian orphanages but I believe
we'll look back with similar outrage or
online harms what greater violation
could there be of childhood than to
entice a child to collaborate in their
own sexual abuse in the privacy and
supposed safety of their own bedroom and
yet this is one of the many crimes that
is occurring on Industrial scale every
day past Horrors like children die Minds
were tackled by robust legislation and
the Online safety bill must continue our
parliament's proud tradition of taking
on vested interests to defend the
welfare of children the Online safety
bill must succeed in its Mission but in
its present form I don't believe it has
sufficiency to drive the determination
that is needed in Tech boardrooms to
tackle the systemic issues the
malevolent algorithms that drive the
sickening content to our children there
is no doubt the potential fines in the
bill are significant but many of these
companies have Deep Pockets and the only
criminal sanctions offer failure to
share data with ofcom and the inquest
following the tragic death of Molly
Russell was an example of that
no one could be held personally
responsible for what happens to Molly
and I want to pay tribute to Ian Russell
Molly's father whose courage in the face
of such personal tragedy has made such
an enormous difference in bringing to
light the extent of online harms only
personal criminal liability will drive
proactive change and we've seen this in
other areas such as the financial
services industry and the construction
industry so I'm absolutely delighted
that the government has recognized the
necessity of senior manager liabilities
after much campaigning across the house
at four Tech bosses and committed to
introducing it in the other place and I
want to thank the Secretary of State and
her team for the very constructive very
positive way that they have engaged with
supporters I certainly will would she
not also like to say the nspcc have been
absolutely magnificent in supporting us
I was coming on to that absolutely and
so the advantage of doing this in the
other place is that we can widen the
scope to all child's sake well all
appropriate child safer duties Beyond
just section 11 and perhaps tackle upon
feet and child sexual abuse material as
well and we will I believe now have a
groundbreaking bill that will hold to
account powerful Executives who
knowingly allow our children to be
harmed and there are those who say and
we heard some yesterday not least the
tech companies that should we should not
be seeking to criminalize site directors
there are those who worry that this will
reduce Tech investment but that hasn't
happened in Ireland there are those that
say this senior manager liability
Amendment will put a great burden on
tech companies to comply to which I say
great and there are those who are
worried that this will set an
international precedent to which I say
even better because nothing should cause
greater outrage in our society than the
harming of innocent children and in a
just Society founded on the rule of law
those who harm children or allow
children to be harmed should expect to
be punished by the Lord and this is what
this amendment seeks to do and I look
forward to working with my right
honorable friend and others to bring
forward a suitable amendment in the
other place and I do want to offer my
sincere thanks to the nspcc especially
Rich Collard and to the outstanding
child'sheimer's of the telegraph who
have so effectively supported this
campaign and I also want to pay tribute
to my honorable friend the member of
stoke for stone without whose
determination knowledge and experience
it would not have been possible to
achieve this change my honorable friend
has been known as Mr brexit but as he
said even before he was Mr brexit he was
Mr Child Protection being involved as he
said with the protection of children act
in 1978 and it's certainly advantageous
in negotiations to work with someone who
knows vastly more about legislation than
pretty much anyone else involved and and
he sat through the debate in December
when we were discussing the right on the
ladies Amendment and we sat there at the
back on those benches while the vote was
taking place and he said I think we can
do this and he spent the next week in
the public bill office and most of his
recess buried in legislation so I do
want to pay a tribute for his
outstanding work so Mr Mr Speaker once
Mr Deputy speaker once again I do thank
the Secretary of State for her
commitment to this and I do think this
will continue our parliament's proud
history of protecting children
the energy
Deputy speaker and I I Rise to fully
support this bill and the amount of work
that honorable members have made over
the previous months and years to be able
to get us to where we are now and I'd
also like to say that in particular I
supported the Amendments my honorable
friend from Dover and my honorable
friend from uh peniston and stocksbridge
and my runtime of a friend from Stone
um because these were the right things
to do
um we cannot have effectively illegal
advertising for illegal activities on on
platforms where we wouldn't allow it on
television and so why would we allow it
on other platforms that people can
easily access and with respect to
um uh to to harmful uh content with
regard to Children
um why shouldn't we make senior managers
of these hugely Rich organizations
actually have their minds focused on if
I don't do my job properly and protect
children I may go to prison I do seem to
think that actually the threat of prison
will focus these individuals
does my older friend agree that really
this is not just an assault on the
person as physical but it's an assault
on their minds that's what's going on
and it's destroying them
um my rental River friend is absolutely
correct and and obviously you know what
what this is all about is we're quite
often these senior managers are very
high profile individuals with um with PR
budgets that are probably larger than
many countries across the world and and
actually thinking about fines really
what they would be doing is just putting
those fines into their business plans it
wouldn't really affect a cultural change
as my honorable friend has said on many
occasions before we need this cultural
change to make sure that these companies
say what are we doing to make sure that
children are being protected and so
that's why I wholeheartedly support it
I'd also like to say thank you very much
to the Secretary of State and ministers
and officials who really have with all
of us including back benches have
actually talked with us talked through
things taken them seriously which means
we are aware we need to be now which is
which is fantastic and
um as a child of the 1970s and apparent
now I never envisaged that we would have
to be having the kind of conversations
with our children
um things they come across and they say
mom what is this uh should should I go
and find
um a needle so I can inject this into my
and you know this this is the kind of
content the horrifying content that that
parents and teachers come across and I
have to say schools with their digital
footprint training do a fantastic job to
make sure that we can all start to have
these conversations and I have to say my
honorable and right honorable friends
um yes I'm grateful for me honor to The
Honorable way the opponents of our cause
claim that we are curbing freedom but in
fact it's not freedom for these people
offer it's the it's that they turn their
habits into slaves of cruel kallus
conglomerates
but I absolutely agree with my right
honorable friend and if Freedom means
that your children become collateral
damage to harmful and dangerous people
well then we need to have some real
conversations about what Freedom really
is all about but as a child of the 1970s
who thankfully the only experience I had
to have was television and three
channels and my my honorable friends
were like I liked Zorro and Tonto coming
into their Wild West Town where all the
baddies are standing there waiting to
annihilate us to save the villagers and
I thank you very much for that and I
look forward to supporting this bill all
the way through
thank you Mr Deputy speaker legislating
in an online world is incredibly complex
it's of pitfalls the digital world moves
so very fast it's very difficult to make
legislation that is both effective and
future proof I really don't want to wind
up my right on my friend the member for
stone anymore by mentioning the word
Europe but actually I'm very proud that
I worked alongside other British MEPS to
introduce the gdpr the the tech
companies hated it they especially hated
the penalties the gdpr is not perfect
legislation but it did fundamentally
transform the way that online actors
think about the need to protect personal
data the need to protect confidentiality
and privacy and the bill that is through
that go through the house today can do
exactly the same thing in totally
transforming the way in which Online
safety is treated especially for
children I've been a pride champion of
the of the internet watch foundation for
over a decade I've worked with them to
help tackle That Hideous abuse of sexual
abuse we see of Children online as
children's minister join the periods of
this bill I'm very aware of the serious
harms that the online world can and does
pose and I am so proud that ministers
have put protecting children at the very
front of this bill I like others has
signed new Clause too I see it like this
if God forbid in a hospital the staff
were complete are constantly and
repeatingly causing harm to children and
the hospital boss was aware of this
turning a blind eye condoning it that we
would all expect that hospital boss to
end up in the courts and if necessary in
prison and Tech bosses should have the
same so thank you to the government for
saying that you're going to go along the
Irish style of legislation here and I
look forward to seeing that my new
amendments Amendment 38 new Clause 8
which wasn't in scope relate to eating
disorders they're intended to make it
very clear that Eating Disorders should
be treated as seriously as other forms
of self-harm I'd like to thank everybody
in this chamber who spoke to me so
kindly after I spoke about my own
experience of it as a former anorexic in
the last debate and all of those outside
this chamber who since contacted me
anorexia was the biggest killer of all
mental illnesses is a sickness that has
a slow and long burning fuse but all too
often that fuses deadly it's been a
terrifying race in cases and it's very
clear that social media posts which
glamorize Eating Disorders are helping
to fuel this epidemic
I'm not talking about content that's
just advertising a diet I'm talking
about egregious content in content which
is encouraging viewers to starve
themselves in some cases too many cases
to starve themselves to their death
content promoting each Eating Disorders
is no less dangerous than other content
promoting other forms of self-harm in
fact given the huge numbers of people
suffering from eating disorders around
one and a quarter million people in this
country it may be considered as the most
dangerous it's not only dangerous for
children it's dangerous and vulnerable
adults too
mind amendments as I said Endeavor to
make it clear that content promoting
Eating Disorders should be treated in
the same way as seriously as content
performing other forms of self-harm I'd
like to thank all of those who've signed
it including former Health ministers
former digital ministers the current
chair the health select committee and
the women and equality select committee
and the former chair of the woman on
quality select committee I hope that by
laying these amendments and the fact
that MPS of such experience have signed
them we're sending a very clear message
to those in the other place that we hear
treat this issue very very seriously my
amendments are not the clearest legal
way in which to manage this issue and
therefore I do not intend to move the
specific Amendment today but I'd like to
thank the Secretary of State the
minister responsible bit for the bill as
well as the Justice Minister I know that
they want to move amiss they met with me
earlier today they've agreed that we
will find a way to help that vulnerable
adults as well as children for being
constantly subjected this to this type
of killing content and I look forward to
continuing to work with ministers and
members of the other place to find the
best and legally water type way forward
thank you
Marcus fish
Mr Speaker the um it's a pleasure to
follow my honorable friend who made a
very powerful speech and I completely
agree with her about the importance of
treating eating disorders of the same
scale of harm as other things within
this bill I was the meat the media
analyst for Merrill Lynch about 22 years
ago and I made a speech about the future
of media and I did mention then the
landscape changed towards one of
self-generated media but I have to say
that I never thought we would get to
where it is now and and what the effect
is I was in the Pizza Express on
Gloucester Road the other day at sort of
birthday party time and there was an 11
year old boy standing in the uh queue
doom doom scrolling
Tick Tock videos rather than talking to
his friends and I just thought that that
was just a really tragic indication of
where we've got to but these digital
platforms are also critical sources of
information and our public discourse and
up to 80 percent of of information is
gathered by uh individuals across the
country now from these sources and but
it's just not right that we should have
trust in these digital platforms they're
algorithms that promote and de-promote
and their interfaces that engage they
are designed as we've heard to make
people addicted to the peer validation
and augmentation of particular points of
view they are driving people down tribal
rabbit holes to the point where they
can't talk to each other or even listen
to another point of view
no wonder that 50 of people young people
are unhappy or or anxious when they use
social media and these algorithmic
models are the problem so trust in these
platforms is wrong their promotion or
deep promotion of messages and ideas is
opaque it is often subjective and
subject to inappropriate influence it is
right that we tackle illegal activity
and that harms to children and the
vulnerable are aggressed are addressed
and I support the attempt to do this in
this bill and it's true that those
responsible for the big platforms must
be held to account for the way that they
operate them but trusting in them is
wrong
I worry that compliance with their terms
of service might become a tick box
Absolution of their responsibility for
unhappiness for anxiety and for harm and
what about harm to our public sphere our
discourse our processes of debate of
policy making of science to trust the
Platforms in all of this would be wrong
we know that they've enabled censorship
Elon musk's release of the Twitter files
has shown incontrovertibly that the big
digital platforms actively Center people
and ideas and not always according to
reasonable moderation they censor them
according to their company biases they
Center them by political requests they
Center them with and on behalf of the
three letter government agencies and
they censor them at private companies
behest to control information on their
products and and to control the public
policy debate around them and censorship
itself creates mistrust in our discourse
so to trust these big platforms just to
do the right thing always is wrong it
isn't right that they should be able to
hide behind that under service bury
issues in the ofcom processes in the
bill pay lip service potentially to a
tick box exercise of merely having
regards to the importance of freedom of
expression they might think they can
just write a report hire a few overseers
and get away scot-free with their
cynical accumulation and sale of their
addicted users data and manipulation of
their views the government has rightly
acknowledged that addressing these
issues of Online safety is a work in
progress but we mustn't think that the
big platforms are that interested in
helping they and their miseries models
are the problem so I hope that the
government to conclude and those in the
other place will bring forward in this
bill stronger liabilities against
stronger duties to stop things that are
actually harmful to promote freedom of
expression properly to ensure that
people have ready and full access to the
full range of ideas and opinions to be
fully transparent in public and in real
time about the way that content is being
promoted or depromoted on their
platforms because just to trust in them
is insufficient the precedent I'm afraid
has been set that the digital platforms
can be used to censor ideas and that
this is not the future this is happening
right now when artificial intelligence
comes it will just get even worse I I
trust my colleagues on the front bench
and in the other house that they will
work hard to improve this bill as I know
it can be
Position will be five minutes
Rachel McLean thank you thank you very
much Mr Deputy speaker I strongly
support the Online safety bill it's a
landmark piece of legislation which
promises to put the UK at the very front
of the pack and I'm very proud to see it
there we must tackle online abuse while
protecting free speech I believe this
bill does get that balance right I was
pleased to serve as part of the last
session on the bill committee and I'm
absolutely delighted to see the bill
return to the chamber today because the
quicker it can get onto the statute book
The more children we can protect from
devastating
I particularly welcome the strengths and
protections for children requiring
platforms to clearly articulate what
they're doing in their terms of service
to enforce age requirements on the site
it will go some way to reassuring
parents that their children's developing
brains will not be harmed by early
exposures toxic degrading and demeaning
extreme forms of pornography evidence is
clear that early exposure over time
warps young girls views of what's normal
in a relationship and the result of that
is that they struggle to form healthy
equal relationships for boys this type
of sexual activity is how they actually
learn about sex it normalizes abusive
non-consensual and violent acts boys
grow up into men whose neural circuits
become habituated to this type of
imagery they actually require it
regardless of the boundaries of consent
that they learn about in their sex
education classes I know this is a very
difficult and troubling subject but we
must not be afraid to tackle it and this
is what we are doing with this
legislation and it's well established at
the rise of this type of pornography on
the internet over time has driven the
very troubling and pernicious rise in
violence against so many girls
perpetrated by men as well as peer on
peer child sex abuse and exploitation
during committee we had a very good
debate about the need for greater
criminal sanctions to hold directors
individually to account to drive a more
effective safety culture in the
boardroom and I'm very proud to serve in
this chamber with my right honorable
friend from Stone my honorable friend
from penistone and Stockbridge and I've
listened to all the work that they've
done on their Amendment new Clause 2 I
commend them heartily for it I listened
very carefully to The Minister's remarks
in committee and I want to thank him and
Secretary of State for their detailed
engagement and I really welcome the
plans to introduce measures to
strengthen individual criminal liability
for directors of tech companies I would
make the point that in response to
concerns raised by some this will deter
investment in the UK or result in a tech
Exodus it's nonsense it's absolute
nonsense it's not taking place in
Ireland which still hosts many leading
industry headquarters I'm a former Tech
entrepreneur part of the founding team
of one of the UK's largest software
Publishers and I want to assure the
house that this forward-leading
legislation and regulation that requires
Innovation to solve compliance and user
problems is exactly what drives the
engineers to do what they do best which
is to solve problems and develop
Solutions in the interests of their
customers that are valuable across a
host of Industries and sectors and the
new measures will cement the UK's role
as a world leader in the space underpin
our ability to continue to play a
leading role in the software industry
where we lead others will follow and it
gives our thought leaders the
opportunity to develop bespoke Solutions
and ensure children's ages are verified
in a robust way and that disgusting
child sex abuse materials is removed and
is not proliferated
in response to violence against women
and girls there are sensible and
workable plans set out to make coercive
and controlling Behavior a priority
offense to make platforms take this
stuff down without women and girls
having to contact them every single time
and I welcome the work on creating codes
of practice and considering the
challenges Mr Deputy speaker that's
around this whole area I believe this
bill does a really good job of
protecting and upholding freedoms of
speech that we hold dear in our
democracy as a feminist I need to be
able to express my view protected under
the equality act that biological sex is
immutable I should not be hounded off
the internet or threatened with violence
for stating that view this is absolutely
the same time that we should all seek to
improve and support the experiences and
the and the and the and experiences and
support of transgender people we can do
both at the same time we have to have a
nuance and a balanced and a
compassionate debate we are in an era
where our discussion forums have become
polarized we're crossing New Frontiers
but we can't express the status quo our
democracy depends on it yeah
Mr Deputy speaker I stand to talk uh
broadly about new Clause 2 which I'm
very pleased that the government is
engaging on and the work of my right
honorable honorable friends who have
done incredible work to make that happen
I I share their relation because as
probably I think the only member who's
been in both the joint committee and a
fantastic German and in both committees
um I've seen the passage of this bill
over the past year or so and been uh
really opened and and happy with the way
that the government is engaged including
on Zach's law which will ensure that
trolls can't send flashing images to
people with epilepsy and so I share the
Elation of my colleagues as I did with
the member for stourbridge when we were
very successful in convincing the
government to make that happen
um May I just really reiterate the
learnings from The Joint Committee and
from the committee uh earlier last year
when we took evidence from these Tech
Giants and they are giants it was very
clear that as Giants do because they're
so big they didn't see the damage
underfoot that they were causing the
harm that they were doing to to those
but also they were blind to it they
chose not to see the damage they were
doing I remember challenging one of the
big Tech Giants in as a witness to
whether they'd even followed the
committee and the the harms that they
were causing to vulnerable children and
to adults and I was fascinated by the
way that they just didn't care in my
view their responses were well we're
doing enough already we're already
trying you know we're putting billions
of pounds into supporting uh people who
were doing uh who were being harmed by
this they just didn't see the reality on
the ground of young people uh being
damaged and my namesake uh Ian Russell I
remember when interviewing him I I was
heartbroken that evening because we had
uh children of a similar age and I just
could not imagine having to have that
conversation that he would have had to
have had with his family and friends uh
through that terrible tragedy but yes I
would I'm most grateful um this is my
honorable friend aware that Ian Russell
has pointed out that 26 of young people
who presented hospital with self-harm
and suicide attempts have accessed such
predatory irresponsible and willful
online content
absolutely my right honorable friend is
right but also one of the real horrors
of it was that Facebook weren't going to
release as I understand it I don't want
to break any uh any rules here but as I
understand it wouldn't release uh the
the content that his daughter had been
viewing to be able to help with with the
process of healing
um if I may though I just want to touch
upon another point which hasn't been
raised today which is about the role of
a future committee I appreciate this
isn't part of the bill but I do strongly
feel that within this house we should
have a separate new committee for the
Online safety bill
um if I may take that a bit further and
the reason why is that the internet and
the world of social media is changing
dramatically the metaverse is
approaching very rapidly and we're
seeing uh the rise in virtual reality
and augmented reality but also
artificial intelligence is changing the
way that we even believe what we see
online at a rate that we cannot even
imagine I have a few predictions myself
I have anticipation in the next few
years we'll probably have the first
number one book that's probably written
by AI the first song written by AI you
can now hear online uh fake voices and
or
um impersonations by AI of people where
you probably have uh songs and song
created in ways that fool us that will
fool children even more I have no doubt
that in the coming months and years
we'll see a rise perhaps even of
children suing their parents for sharing
content of them when they were younger
without permission we're going to see a
changing Dynamic of the way that young
people engage with new content and what
they anticipate from it my girlfriend's
making a valuable contributions about as
I expected he would having discussed
with this with him from the very
beginning of the work he's done what
he's describing is not only the
combination of heartlessness and
carelessness on the powerful tech
companies but also the Curious marriage
of an anarchic future coupled with the
tyranny of their control of that future
and he's absolutely right that if we're
going to do anything about that in this
place we won't need to have an ongoing
role for a committee of the kind he
recommends I thank my uncle friend for
his his comments on this and I will wrap
up shortly uh Mr Deputy speaker on that
point I've talked before that the use of
algorithms Within These platforms is in
my mind very similar to addictive drugs
it it gets people addicted it gets them
to change their behaviors it gets them
to cut off from their friends and family
and then it directs them in ways that
you would not allow if you could wrap
your arms around them and stop it but
you they don't in their own bedrooms
they're doing it in classrooms they're
doing it in playgrounds the benefit of
this bill and I wholly applaud the work
that's being done on this yes there's
ways that it can be improved and I think
a committee in the future that looks at
ways to improve it as the Dynamics of
social media changes is going to be
essential but I think what it what it
will be doing today by going through to
the Lords will be a major shift forward
in protecting our young people for now
and for the future thank you yeah thank
you for your patience Siobhan Bailey
thank you Mrs Deputy speaker I Rise to
speak to amendments 2 and 53 and as you
know Mr Deputy speaker I've been
campaigning to tackle Anonymous abuse
for many years now I've been working
with the Fantastic clean up the internet
organization Stroud residence and also
the brilliant dcms team we've been
really focused on practical measures
that are going to empower social media
users to protect themselves from
Anonymous abuse and I'm pleased to say
that the government has accepted our
campaign proposals and these are to
introduce verification options to give
people the option to be followed and
follow only verified accounts if that is
what they choose and to ensure that you
know who is and who isn't verified this
also assists with ensuring that the
positive parts of anonymity can continue
online as there are many I respectfully
think that this work is even more
important now that we've seen the
removal of the legal but harmful Clauses
because we know that many issues will
tip into uh be viewed by children and
many any vulnerable adults also want to
be protected online but we're not
resting on this campaign win as we want
to see the verification measures really
work in the real world and for social
media companies to adopt them quickly
without any confusion about their duties
separately I think Clarity is the order
of the day because we know that ofcom
the regulator is going to have an awful
lot to do due to the excellent Clauses
throughout this legislation but this is
urgent we must not forget that Anonymous
social media accounts are spewing out
hateful bile every single minute of the
day children and vulnerable adults are
left terrified it's much more scary to
receive comments and um and suicide
comments self-harm bullying anorexia
pushes and when it's from people that
you don't know who they are or it's far
far more scary Financial scammers tend
to hide behind anonymity faceless Bots
calls Mayhem and start nasty pylons
perverts know that when they send a
cyber flashing dick pic to an
unsuspecting woman that it's very
unlikely if it comes from Anonymous
account that it's going to be traced
back to them so having the tools to not
see unverified nonsense or abuse and
switch that off and know that the people
that you are following are real is
really powerful and important so I'm
Keen for the minister to and the
government to adopt my proposed
amendments at 52 and 53 they're by no
mean the most sexy and Jazzy amendments
that are before this house today you
will see that they are more tweaks than
amendments and changing to wording to
bring the legislation up to date
considering recent changes but also to
ensure that where people are verified
that it's obvious so blue ticks are a
really good example and that was part of
my campaign in the first point from
discussions I understand that the
government are considering adopting the
amendments I thank members of the House
for calling them sensible and for
backing them I think this is really
important finally I've made the case
many many times that the public are
expecting us to act and be strong in
this area but they're also expecting
things to be happening very quickly
we've waited a very long time so I think
giving people the power to protect
themselves and tools to to dutes whether
it's a sliding of a button or to switch
something off I think that is incredibly
important and and my great hope from the
campaigning that I have done is that
young people and adults as well will
think about only following unverified
accounts through an active choice and
that turning off any of I will give away
thank you just on that specific point
just you realize that the empowerment
duties that about verified non-verified
users only apply to adult users children
will not have the option to toggle off
um unverified users because the
childhood user and payment duties do not
allow that to happen thank you the
evidence that we've received is that
that it's parents that need that need
the powers as well so we we want to make
sure that um that the uh the the
I want to normalize actually I want to
normalize the uh ability to turn off
anonymize accounts and I think what we
will see is for children will do that
very naturally but also to try and
persuade uh their parents to to take
those stances and to have those
conversations in the home I think it's
obviously something I need to take up
with her and think quite carefully about
as matters proceed through the other
place as well but I've mentioned parents
particularly
um where we we know that parents are
very very scared about what their
children are seeing online I welcome uh
what the minister is trying to do with
this bill I welcome the legislation that
um and the openness to to change the
legislation I mean we're all called
Rebels whenever we do anything to
improve legislation these days but the
reality is that it is our job and I
think we're sending this legislation in
a better place uh to the other house
Minister Paul Scully thank you Mr Deputy
speaker there's a lot to cover in my
short time but first of all let me thank
members for their contribution during
today's debate we had great
contributions from the audible and right
honorable members for Ponte brief and
with them from barking uh and I have to
put that right having not mentioned her
last time uh gospel Aberdeen North
Kenworth and South and the former
Secretary of State Plymouth Sutton and
devonport and reading East both uh and
indeed leads these are happily Meet The
Honorable member for Plymouth Sutton and
Davenport to talk about Intel content as
he asked for and indeed the members for
reading East and Leeds East talk about
Ollie Stevens and Joe nyhill too really
tragic examples and it was good to hear
them being the tribute for the changes
in the legislation to be mentioned in
this place the right humble member for
South northamptonshire strangford Dover
Stone and I'm glad he gave a three-weet
of its speech there and I'll have to
look at the two one for the winter books
that he's been eating
um The Honorable member pedeston and
stocksbridge great Grimsby Chelmsford
Yeovil and I when he talked about Doom
scrolling I would recommend him to maybe
talk to the on my honorable member for
South Holland and the deepings because
he's quoting of GK Chesterton shows the
advantages of reading books rather than
just scrolling through your phone and
indeed the uh Redditch uh Watford and
Andy Stroud so thank you very much and
indeed contributions join the
recommittal process as well the changes
that have been made to this bill join
that process have strengthened the
protections it can offer let me just
turn to some of the uh the points that
were raised now we've carefully reviewed
new Clause 2 and I'm sympathetic to the
aims of the amendment we've already
demonstrated our commitment elsewhere in
the bill to strengthening the
protections for children in this bill by
bringing forward a series of amendments
at previous stages of Passage to achieve
this in addition the bill already
includes Provisions to make senior
managers liable for failure failing to
prevent a provider committing an offense
failure to comply with information
notices
but we're committed to ensuring that
children are safe online so we'll work
with these honorable members and others
to bring an effective amendment in the
other place which delivers our shared
aims of holding people accountable for
their actions in a way which is
effective and targeted towards child
safety whilst ensuring the UK remains an
attractive place for technology
companies to invest and grow we need to
take time to get this right we intend to
base our Amendment on the Irish Online
safety and media regulation act 2022
which actually over on a glue was
largely based on our work in here which
introduces individual criminal liability
for failure to comply with the notice to
end contravention uh in that in line
with that approach the final government
Amendment at the end of ping pong
between the other place and this place
will be carefully designed to capture
instances where senior managers or those
purporting to act in that capacity have
consented or connived in ignoring
enforceable requirements risking serious
harm to children the criminal penalties
including imprisonment and fines will be
commensurate in with similar offenses
whilst this amendment will not affect
those who have acted in good faith to
comply in a proportionate way it gives
the ACT additional teeth as we've heard
to deliver the change that we all want
and ensure that people are held to
account if they fail to properly protect
children as my right honorable family
member for with them has made clear
child protection and strong
implementation are at the heart of this
legislation the Bill's strongest
protections are for children and
companies will be held accountable for
the safety of children and I can't
guarantee timings the timings that she
asked for but uh but we will not dilute
our commitment and uh and we've already
started speaking to companies about the
in this area but also continue to work
with her and others I will give away him
that I'll give away
I thank my honorable friend uh my old
friend has rightly prioritized the
protection of children and he will
recall that throughout this debate a
number of honorable members have asked
the government to consider the amendment
that will be brought forward in the
other place by the noble baroness Kidron
which will require coroners to have
access to data in cases uh where the
tragic death of a child may be related
to social media and other online
activities so is it possible for my
honorable friend to give a commitment
from the dispatch box that the
government would look favorably at that
Amendment
I like my writable fans and coroners
already have some uh powers in this area
but we do hear the cases that he and
others have raised about of where that's
not been the case so yes indeed would
happily work with Barona schedule and
others to uh uh to look favorably on
making changes where necessary and I
will give away so yes the
Miss has been around protecting children
but as he was as concerned as I am in
terms of the disinformation and
misinformation and the societal impacts
yes and and our democracy not just in
our country but elsewhere and uh given
that the member for Watford suggested a
standing committee that would be able to
monitor these impacts is that something
that he will reconsider well I think
what we'll need to do I Thank The
Honorable lady for that intervention in
terms of uh future proofing this it's
one of the reasons that we've tried to
make the legislation as flexible as
possible as technology technologically
neutral as possible to be able to adapt
with with changes and I think we will uh
need to review this legislation or it
and indeed I'm sure as technology
changes come back with new legislation
in the future to make sure that we
continue to be World beating but let's
see where we end up with that now I I
will give away very briefly but it's
just foreign
if it is the case that coroners can't
access station information they need to
go about their duties as was the
frustration of the Molly Russell case is
he saying that the government will be
prepared to close that loop on the laws
well I think we'll certainly work with
others to to to to to address this and
if there is a loophole there we will
absolutely you know look to uh to to act
on that because we want to make sure
that this power I won't give away for
just a second oh I should know I will
get something I'm grateful to the
minister of the giving away it was
commenting on um my earlier my earlier
remarks around new cruels too and the
specifics around a timetable if I may
suggest completely recognize that so
much of this work is under development
um in my remarks I had asked for a
timetable in real life in regards to
engagement with the tech firms but also
transparency to this house on the
progress that is made around developing
the regulations around criminal
liability I think it's important that
this house sees that and we follow every
single stage of that process oh well
indeed I thank my envelope engine look
we want to have as many conversations
with with members of all sides on this
area so I hope in that um operation we
can be as transparent as possible we
have already started the conversation uh
Secretary of State and I met uh some of
the big uh tech companies just yesterday
talking about exactly this area now my
uh honorable and my honorable friends
the members for Dover at South Holland
and the deepings maidenhead and others
are absolutely right to highlight
concerns about legal small boats
Crossing and the harm that can be caused
to people crossing in dangerous
situations the use of Highly dangerous
methods to enter this country including
unseaworthy or small and overcrowded
boats and refrigerated lorries presents
a huge challenge to us all like other
forms of serious and organized crime
organized immigration uh crime and
dangers lives has a corrosive effect on
society puts pressure on border security
resources and diverts money from our
economy and as the Prime Minister has
said stopping these Crossings is one of
the government's top priorities for the
next year the situation needs to be
resolved and we will not hesitate to
take action wherever that can have the
most effect including through this bill
organized crime groups can continue to
facilitate most migrant Journeys to the
UK and have no respect for human life
exploiting vulnerable migrants treating
them as Commodities and knowingly put
people in life-threatening situations
organized crime gangs are increasingly
using social media to facilitate migrant
Crossings and we need to do more to
prevent and disrupt the crimes
facilitated through these platforms we
need to share best practice improve our
detection methods and take steps to
close illegal Crossing routes as the
behavior of organized crime groups and
methods involved however this amendment
risks having unforeseen consequences for
the bill it could bring into question
the meaning of the term contents
elsewhere in the bill with unpredictable
implications for how the courts and
companies interpret this now following
constructive discussions with my
honorable friends and The Honorable
friend for a member for maidenhead I can
now now confirmed that in order to
better tackle illegal immigration
encouraged by organized gangs the
government will add section 2 of the
modern slavery act to the list of
priority offenses section two makes it
an offense to arrange or facilitate the
travel of another person including
through recruitment with a view to their
exploitation but we'll also add section
24 of the Immigration Act to the
priority offenses list in schedule seven
although the offenses instead section 2
cannot be carried out online paragraph
33 of the schedule it states that
priority illegal contact includes the
inquiry offenses relating to the
offenses that are listed therefore
aiding betting counseling conspiring etc
those offenses by posting videos of
people crossing the channel which show
that activity in a positive light could
be an offense that's committed online
and therefore Falls within what is
priority illegal content the result of
this amendment would therefore be that
platforms would have to proactively
remove that content so I'm grateful to
my honorable and right honorable friends
the member for Dover South Holland and
the deep in have made net for raising
this really important issue and I'll be
happy to offer them a meeting with my
officials to discuss the drafting of
this moment ahead of it being tabled in
the other place
now we recognize the strength of feeling
on the issue of harmful conversion
practices and remain committed to
protecting people from these practices
and making sure that they can live their
lives free from the threat of harm or
abuse we've had constructive engagement
with the manual friend the member from
Rutland and Melton on her Amendment
which seeks to prevent children from
seeing harmful online content on
conversion practices it's right that
this issue is tackled through a
dedicated and tailored legislative
approach which is why we're announcing
today that the government will publish a
draft bill which will set out a proposed
approach to ban conversion practices
this will apply to England and Wales the
bill would protect everybody including
those targeted on the basis of their
sexuality or being transgender the
government will publish the bill shortly
and will ask for pre-legis scrutiny by a
joint committee in this this
parliamentary session this is a complex
area and pre-legis scrutiny exists to
help ensure that any Bill introduced to
Parliament does not cause unintended
consequences it will also ensure that
the benefit uh the bill benefits from
stakeholder expertise and input from
parliamentarians the legislation must
not through a lack of clarity harm the
growing number of children and young
adults experiencing gender related
distress through inadvertently
criminalizing or chilling legitimate
conversations parents or clinicians may
have with their children it's an
important issue and it's a targeted and
robust approach which a dedicated bill
will provide I only have three minutes
I'm afraid so I won't be able to give
away at this stage but in terms of the
labor amendments the government can't
accept amendments to add the adult
safety duties and concept of content
that's harmful to adults back into the
bill these duties and the harmful
content definition were removed from the
bill at committee stage in order to
protect free speech and ensure that the
bill does not incentivize tech companies
to censor legal content it's not
appropriate for government to decide
whether legal content is harmful to
adult users and then to require
companies to risk assess and set terms
for such content many stakeholders and
parliamentarians were justifiably
concerned about the consequences of
doing so and I share those concerns
however the government recognizes the
importance of giving the users the tools
and information they need to keep
themselves safe online and that's why
we've introduced to the Belt a fairer
simpler approach the triple shield for
adults
now we've talked about a little about a
user empowerment I'm not going to have
time to cover
um some of that but we do believe that
we have struck the right balance between
empowering adult users over the content
they see and engage with online while
upholding rights to free expression and
for those reasons I've set out I'm not
able to accept the honorable members
Amendment so I hope they will therefore
withdraw them in terms of the government
amendments here they are consequential
amendments having moved and removed the
legal uh about harmful sections and they
were debated extensively at the
committee stage though government
recognized my my right my friend uh
honorable friends from Stroud's
concerned about anonymous online abuse
and I applaud her important campaigning
in this area and we will work
um we do expect ofcom to recommend
effective tools for compliance with the
requirement that these tools can be
applied to users who wish to filter out
non-verified users and I agree that this
is a really important issue as is there
issue uh covering uh Amendment her
Amendment 52 and I'm happy to continue
working with her and um to deliver her
objectives in this area in terms of my
honorable friend from Chelmsford again
we take the issue incredibly seriously
she has spoken really powerfully on this
we are committed to introducing a new
Communications offense of the
intentional encouragement and assistance
of self-harm and that will apply to all
victims of encouragement children as
well as adults
I can't don't having I don't have a time
doing a thing but let me just again
thank all members attending for the
contribution to days today can I I just
want to pay all my tribute to my
officials and to all of the ministers
who worked on this over such a long time
thank you
is it your pleasure that new Clause 1 be
withdrawn
the nucleus won by leave withdrawn under
the order of the House of the 5th of
December 2022 I must now put the
questions necessary to bring proceedings
on consideration to a conclusion new
Clause 4 has been selected for a
separate decision Alex Davies Jones to
move neutrals for formally
move question is that new Clause 4 be
added to the bill as many of that
opinions say aye
aye country gnome
[Applause]
division clear the lobbies